[Music]
hey
welcome to another episode
of fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i am
mark bernardin
hey this is cute mark they're not
sponsors but just a shout out to these
folks
you know lately i've been uh smoking
clothes on the show clove cigarettes
because you're a refined continental
gentleman
apparently they're not legal in many
places anymore so
the good folks at happy flower company
sent me actual cbd smokes
they says hey kevin huge fan blah blah
blah
dogma's genius don't blah blah past that
anyway i am not a tech guy so this uh
has taken days to figure out a way to
reach you
um but saw your most recent show where
you were smoking cbd pre-rolls
anyway i know that you already have a
cannabis company i do we sell
jane salam bob uh strained weed with
good folks at caviar gold and they also
make a hemp version
non-thc version of our product which
i've spoke on the show before
um he says uh but just for on the record
i would love to send you some of our
hemp cbd stuff uh just so that
you could say that is what you're
smoking or try it
we are a family-run boutique
small batch farm just north of denver
we have been in the can a business of
cannabis in one form or another for
15 years and we started happy flower
company back in uh
2019. anyway check us out
happyflowercompany.com they sent me cbd
smokes how kind of them they're looking
out for you man
they are man they're like don't you
don't you don't have clothes you got
this
they're outside of denver which reminds
me if you're in the denver area kids
movies is coming on uh wednesday and i
know this because i'm coming too
i'm gonna be there cut the ribbon in the
mile high state man
uh for the grand opening look around
opening you want to be a part of this
movies nonsense movies in in in uh
denver colorado i just say the first
name
go to movies.com right now
ladies and gentlemen and that's the last
thing i'll have to [ __ ] talk about
this episode because
that guy he's got a bunch
to talk about we're going to talk about
how
[ __ ] mark just
nevermind masters the universe he
mastered [ __ ] kickstarter for
heaven's sakes
um we will spend a good time talking
about the good time that mark had
with uh his splinter kickstarter and
he'll
update us on all that and whatnot
but always before we go anywhere
we got a sponsor and it's not the happy
flower
happy flower company boy i forgot the
name instantly
yeah it's good cbd um
the uh they're they're good people but
they're not the sponsor of this show
mark tell them who's sponsoring the show
tell them who's paying
for fat man beyond so they can sit there
and watch it for free
today's episode is brought to you by
manscaped our go-to for men's
below the waste grueling products and
they've got
a fancy new product that they're
bringing to market
it is the ultra smooth package
look at mark's got it right there in his
hot little hands man
what now there's three different things
in that what's going on
well in the ultra smooth package you
have uh let's see
a crop exfoliator you know which is the
gentle exfoliant for your grown area
yeah crop gel
which is a clear groin shaving gel
and then sounds like lube to me
indeed the piece to resistance is
the oh the little razor
that now comes yeah baby this is a
three-step kit you got your crop
exfoliator
your crop gel and your crop shaver
designed for shaving that groin area
with confidence kids
indeed competent three precision blades
include
extra wide lubricating strips and a
pivoting head
for the ultimate groin grooming
experience i know you've been sitting
there every day of your life going
when will i have the ultimate groin
grooming experience you're like i've had
some
but nothing this good the ultimate is
coming your way man
and the good folks at manscaped have
brought it to you as we continue to talk
about the good faults
at manscape go to manscape.com right now
ladies and gentlemen man because you can
get 20 off
plus free shipping uh with uh the code
i'm imagining it should be batman
fat man that sounds about right sounds
always uh it's 20
off plus free stripping with the code
fat man at manscaped.com and smooth it
out fellas with manscaped
your balls are going to thank you let me
tell you these man
up down science oh look who's here
ladies and gentleman's banff boys
screwed that up ho ho there we go
new banff oh my god give credit where
credits do where'd you get that
cute little banff cartoon um that was a
guy uh sent that to us on twitter let me
uh
let me get his name um i just wanted to
point out it's fat man 20
is the 920 batman
what's that writing across your face
bamf boy uh it's our
it's the ad that says fat man 20. fat
man 20 is uh
now right across my forehead yeah it is
20 percent off jc's
you're going to be like the joker and
[ __ ] suicide squad we're going to put
fat man 20 crush
grill man um these folks at uh
at manscaped kids
have been such good friends
to the show here at fat man beyond leads
me to believe
that we have a lot of crotch hairy
people in our audience
because the fact that they're still
dropping some dimes that we could tell
you every week so we can implore you
to keep your [ __ ] shorn at manscape.com
that's my new
tagline for them um wonderful company
man
and it makes a hell of a product that
mark
mark uses on his goddamn head from time
to time my most important ball
um show them some love kids can go get
yourself
one of them ultra smooth packages right
now with the crop exfoliator the crop
gel
and the crop shaver man a whole crop of
crop ain't no crop
go to manscape.com get 20 off plus free
shipping
with the code fatman20 thank you bamfoy
at manscaped.com m-a-n-s-c-a-p-e-d
dot com you can get 20 off plus free
shipping with the code
uh fatman20 manscape.com smooth it out
fellas
with manscape man your balls are going
to thank you and we
thank the good folks of manscape for
sponsoring
this week's episode of fat man beyond
very much so all right that's out of the
way
um hey man top of the in the news
uh top of the show uh how you doing
uh chit chat did you watch
[ __ ] army of the dead yet i did i
watched uh
what is today sunday i watched it on
friday oh [ __ ] you beat me i watched it
last night
how enjoyable was that [ __ ] um it was a
lot of fun
it was a lot of fun um you know i am a
sucker
for two things building a team
and a vegas heist you know one of my
favorite movies
um i want to say all the time i'm going
to say it's the best movies seen but
it's very very good is stephen
soderbergh's ocean's 11.
and like that kind of intricacy and the
planning and here's the group and the
the weird motley crew of people who have
some expertise and something
getting together for money um it's uh
and then a couple people who do it for
love there's always a motive of love
um as soon as i like you i too was like
you
son of a [ __ ] i'm in to quote
rick and morty um yeah the [ __ ] the
heist of it just
gave it a skeleton to hang a very
familiar story on the familiar story of
like oh my god zombies but like
this was interesting the idea of like
we've locked them all in vegas and we're
gonna bomb the place but if you can get
in there
there's like [ __ ] 20 million bucks
that you could get out with and then
of course the story gets and twists and
turns
um like he's got his own
little universe to play in now like
because it felt like
correct me if i'm wrong it's open-ended
and they're going to keep going spoilers
like at the end didn't they say
something about like mexico city where
you're like
well perhaps that's where this is going
next where omari hardwick who uh
who is on a plane heading for spoilers
not deep spoilers but spoilers like he's
on he's on a plane
heading to mexico city and he doesn't
land
and so it's clear that story will be
driving down there to say the least
and that it's going to keep going and
and they should keep it going like
you know he once again he put visuals in
that
i've never seen before once again he's
you know kind of taking something that's
familiar
and spun it on its head but once again
this is a guy who did this [ __ ] years
ago
with dawn of the dead so you know i was
like if
this is going to be a netflix dead verse
i'm in and i i suspect this is what i
especially like spoilers kids
if you haven't seen it go check it out
um but how could you have not
like not as long as snyder cut so you
have no excuse not to watch it and stuff
um the the idea
of sentient zombies
of the next generation of zombies there
was a book
was it land of the dead i think he used
to read that king zombie was one of the
characters
and like in that book in that tale of
zombies
they were organized they weren't just
dead like
they were just like we're going to get
these [ __ ] breeders or whatever they
call them i don't know um
but it you know that had there was an
error of that
to this with the a zombie king of sorts
who's smart enough to like
put on a helmet to shield his his head
and he had a queen
and like and then there was that very
disturbing
[ __ ] sequence when you know there's
something inside the body that was like
that that i'm not like that was a bridge
too far but like oh i didn't need that
that that kind of
bumped the [ __ ] out but it was new i
never seen that in something before
um but yeah i like that the idea of like
they're organized and they hate you
just adds more element to the threat now
for some purists
i don't think they appreciate it like
that like they just want oh
they don't even want fast zombies and
stuff but you know there have been so
many zombie things and like the walking
dead's been doing slow
walkers for so long that i'm okay with
you and i'm also okay with the zombie
being like
go ahead putting on a hat yeah totally
i'm like hey man get behind that like
crazy
um but i thought it was like a fun one i
was shocked
that my wife was like i'll watch it and
i was like what the [ __ ] she was like i
like snyder cut i watch it and i was
like right the [ __ ]
oh i had somebody to watch it with man
and um and it was fun
like you know throwing in i'll take a
[ __ ]
zombie tiger any day of the week zombie
horses
like some good [ __ ] no dave batista was
great
anna dela rigora who was like the
helicopter pilot she was in cop-out so i
was watching that movie i was like hey
it's hannah
so i knew some cats as well but the cast
looked like it was made up of a bunch of
folks
from netflix stuff um people have been
in
other stuff you know and it's a spoilers
a hodgepodge of
who does and who don't make it like most
zombie pictures
right um but this being zach
let's just say the body count it's a lot
higher
there's uh there's there is not the pat
happy ending one might hope for
um but actually never get in a zombie
movie there's there's
you know there's always more zombies and
there's like
wonderful tongue and cheek stuff i
especially liked how they did the
backstory because you know
not every zombie backstory is the same
but they are all kind of virtually the
same
so instead of just like you know taking
for granted that this is a world where
this [ __ ] has been going on forever
they kind of do a montage you know
backstory of how vegas becomes the land
of the dead and [ __ ]
uh that's you know fun at the same time
because it's like
done to a bunch of schmaltzy vegas songs
prompted by the most inopportune blow
job in the history of blow jobs
that's right that's how the movie
everything is put in motion you're right
i forgot
man yeah that felt that felt a little
kevin smith
like that's how it happened like
i mean i was so in um i was so delighted
we live in a world where some exec
wasn't like do another draft they were
like oh that's good i've never seen that
before
shoot it yeah um
yeah i i enjoyed it i thought they
[ __ ] did well man
yeah like if i if there was one
complaint that i could have had about it
and there's always one that i can have
you know if you've been here long enough
you know that
is that it's a hair too long for me like
i i i
there's there's a version of this movie
that's like an
hour and 45 and not two and a half that
just kind of has a little bit more
energy
to it um because that's kind of you want
it to feel like dawn of the dead
don't dead it's a tight movie that
doesn't overstay it's well
welcome at all um and that's that's kind
of what i wanted i want a little bit
more
hotness to it but you know where it goes
is fun
how it gets there is fun all the
characters are pretty cool i thought
dignitaro
who's a very late addition to this
particular cast
um was great telling my wife i was just
like
you see her you see tig notaro she never
met
dave bautista she was never there for
any of that so i was like as we watch
this
anytime you see her just know that she
they shot her
months after the and spent like a pretty
penny doing it
yeah a couple million bucks getting
tigner taro into that movie
um but like you know jen my what
jennifer for what it's worth my wife was
just like
why not like otherwise the you know the
only thing people would talk about is
like
what was there before her so she was
like spend the money and
like this thing lives in perpetuity and
if he's beginning a universe as well
it's like start
you know hands-free or scot-free hands
clean whatever [ __ ]
but uh she was good in it uh they were
all she's fun
no weak links in the [ __ ] cast like
it was just well done what do you think
a movie like that costs
um probably you know usually
100 million maybe a bit more um
shot in atlantic city new jersey even
though it was set in vegas there was a
casino that was going to be pulled down
so they shot
from what i understand they shot a bunch
of their stuff there but like you know
there's
[ __ ] watching dave batista jump from
[ __ ] blackjack table a blackjack
table
like like like he's john goodman in the
hallway of [ __ ] martin fink
showing you the life of the mind is good
[ __ ] man
used to be uh fun dave batista
although this week i guess he's doing
the rounds for the movie
and he announced that uh this number
three
guardians would be the last his last
outing is drax
yeah the most adorable reason
uh you know not like i'm done with
disney or any of this [ __ ]
he was like drax is a guy who has his
shirt off all the time and he's like i'm
51
52. he's like getting harder and harder
to take my shirt off and i was like
that's
that's fantastic that is one of the
greatest reasons i've ever heard for
anybody walking away from anything
i won't walk into things if i have to
take my shirt off
so this guy going like i'm going to get
out of this game because it's a real
shirts off kind of game i'm like
come come with me brother yes welcome to
the robe life my friend
yes that layers my friend nobody needs
to see your nipples ever again
yeah i mean it's it's much the same
reason that
you know hugh jackman was like you know
what i can't do this anymore
like i'm i'm cool to get into the shape
the way i have to treat my body every
time we're gonna make a [ __ ]
wolverine movie when i've got to be
shredded with an inch of my life and
it's not good for me and it's hard and
i'm
50 and [ __ ] it like let's let's move on
you got to do other things i forgot he
too was a guy who was like
he's he's like not got out of it because
he's like i'm artistically unsatisfied
with
wolverine he's just like i can't i'm not
gonna [ __ ] do this my whole life is
hard
yeah you know the older you get the
harder it is to [ __ ]
do that to your body and because you
can't sustain that
that's like we're this way we're in this
state we can hold it
for like a month and then i gotta go i
gotta live
and then once you go back to living and
then they're like hey buddy it's uh it's
time for uh
you know x-men origins wolverine you've
got to get in that shape again it's a
year-long process
to train and diet and starve and
gorge all that [ __ ] it's hard um
look why i don't do it yeah same here
the exact reason
otherwise i'd be doing pull-ups i
wouldn't be doing this show
it would be like pull-ups beyond me and
mark would be like
you know what happened this week
cool [ __ ] the zombie movie was a little
long
um the uh it was a little uh chunky but
funky that
zombie movie i did not notice the length
because i
watched in two viewings we were watching
it for about
45 minutes and then uh harley's
boyfriend austin his parents are in town
from richmond virginia
so we went upstairs and played uh bird
bingo that's exactly what it sounds like
instead of numbers
birds are called and you collect them on
a card
can it go it's about the whitest [ __ ]
activity i've ever been involved in mark
myself felt like i was in the middle of
a fluff and utter sandwich but we all
had a good time
playing playing burt bingo uh and then
we played three rounds of it
and uh i was the caller and
uh my wife like who you know
my wife loves me don't get me wrong but
like generally she's like not as
shall we say amused by the likes of a
kevin smith as perhaps hopefully this
audience is
so you know generally she's like ugh
like i get it you're just doing your
thing last night man we came back to the
room and she was like
you were amazing i was like what
and she was like you had something to
say
about all them birds little jokes she's
going sometimes i forget that i'm
married to like
a comedy guy and i'm like yes yes i am a
comedy guy
for heaven's sake but uh it was like i'm
telling you if i wasn't married to
jennifer schwab
i could have [ __ ] jennifer schwab last
night just like that
oh with all my bird humor she was just
like
isn't he dreamy
he made a joke about the american
kestrel him so smart so
so uh we went and played bingo for three
rounds where i apparently was a [ __ ]
bird bingo calling rock star
and would have had sex if we weren't so
eager to get back downstairs and finish
up the zack schneider movie we had the
choice between sex and the zack snyder
movie
and we went for army of the dead which i
got to tell you
was probably more satisfying than the
sex we would have had it was pretty damn
good man so if you haven't seen it yet
and you've got netflix duh like
this is why you're paying man to see
some quality entertainment like this
got to be the beginning of a series got
to be more coming man well there's
definitely
a prequel coming there's an animated
prequel um
you know sort of how some of these
characters got there and
filling in those blanks of those little
snapshots you saw in the beginning of
the movie
not necessary to enjoy this but
definitely nice and way to the
universe and stuff yeah um so yeah
there's more
yeah absolutely more on the horizon
definitely the prequel it's coming
and then i'm sure there's going to be a
sequel because you know it would
surprise me if it doesn't do well
for netflix yeah i'd be shocked i mean
honestly i know some
people like cast aspersions on the
length of the snyder cut of what it did
for hbo max and stuff and
you know netflix certainly isn't like
hey we need this or we're [ __ ] they've
got all the subscribers but to keep all
the subscribers you got to keep that
level of entertainment up there and i
cannot think of
anybody looking for this type of movie
like and i don't mean a zombie movie i
mean like [ __ ]
i want to watch a big old action movie
and stuff say what you will about
the snyder cut fan or no fan but you
know
admittedly it's more meditative than
most
actions this [ __ ] is like
bam bam ba it opens with a blow job and
just keeps coming that'd be my review
mark
very nice on the poster yes put that
right on the poster
um all right man never mind
all that [ __ ] never mind zack snyder
wins again
[ __ ] that's what they should call this
show never mind and beyond
just call it zack snyder wins again
because [ __ ] he just keeps winning this
year maybe he's on fire good for him
let's talk about another winner ladies
and gentlemen
one of us who co-hosts this show
waded into uh deeper creative waters
than they ever have before if you
remember
uh many episodes back mark talked about
wanting to do something he'd never done
before and rather than me tell the story
he'll tell him right now what did you
want to do mark and why
suddenly now did you want to do it uh i
wanted
to as i have for a long time
um direct i wanted to direct a movie
um i've wanted to do it since i was a
kid wanted to do it when i went to
school
found myself in two or three other
different careers between then and now
but i i made myself a promise a few
years back
probably when i turned like 45 that i
was going to direct a movie
before i turned 50. um
and now i am knocking on the door
that date will come this november the
end of november traditionally somewhere
near thanksgiving which means i never
got cupcakes in class when everybody
else got their birthday cupcakes because
we're all off for [ __ ] thanksgiving
august birthday right here i know the
[ __ ] feeling i just sit through a lot
of [ __ ] birthdays and
fair enough i got free cupcakes but i
never got to have my [ __ ] birthday
celebrated in school but that
probably for the best because my mom
wasn't making no cupcakes i would have
been bringing in little debbie oatmeal
pies
and people would have been like aren't
you loved and i'd be like in a way
he drove me to get the pies
kids that [ __ ] you could buy a box of
little debbie smith delights
and oatmeal pies for 89 cents a box a
full box
of like a hundred however they came in
the 70s
and you know the rich kids had hostess
snacks
and then there were folks like myself
who subsisted on little debbie snacks
and now little debbie's been around so
[ __ ] long mark that little debbie is
now the king of the snack cakes hostess
as we know [ __ ] went away at one
point and getting a little debbie's
laughing on top of the mountain now
she's like 89 cents was the key you
[ __ ]
all you kids who had to bring cheap
snacks to your birthdays
at school we built an empire on your
butt anyway
um so yes i made this promise to myself
i saw i saw the uh
the end of the road coming and so
decided that this was going to be the
year
that i i cycled down from i wanted to
direct a feature to i wanted to direct
anything so i'll do it short
and uh and then you know wrote a thing
uh i guess the beginning of the pandemic
i suppose
um the idea was born on a flight back
from doing a fat man show in vancouver
when we had been talking about the
possibility of maybe doing an episode of
jordan peele's twilight zone that never
came to fruition
yeah well their show came to fruition oh
yes get to work on
the grand opening grand closing on that
opportunity
um but the idea was very much supposed
to be a twilight zone episode
and so wrote it up sent it to a couple
of friends
to see if like hey does it look like a
thing you might want to help me make um
so i sent it to you today
who ironically is in the voice cast of
the army of the dead prequel show
um as well as some american gods and
stuff senator trisha helfer who i did a
podcast with
and was from battle star and lucifer and
tiffany smith
who is going to be in our uh shiny new
masters universe
um revelation show and they were like
yeah 100
like this sounds like fun let's let's go
make it short
and i i had always been willing to put a
certain amount of my own money into it
and i was like if i'm going to make this
i i don't necessarily want to have to
ask people for money if i can
if i can spring for this myself then i
will and then i talked to a line
producer who looked at the script
and started breaking it down because
that's what the line producer does land
bruce is in charge of how much things
cost
who gets paid you know how do we how do
we actually make this thing go you know
through every
budget every line of the budget to find
out what it'll cost
he's like oh no you're gonna need like
140 000 to do this
because you are not doing a short that
is you know
a road trip or two people in a hotel
room or a bad breakup or
we have a restaurant like no you need
you need stuff you need effects you need
makeup you need um you need steps
and so the number she gave me frightened
me
and i never for a second thought that we
would be able to
make this money and i think we talked
about it last week this the last show
we did was before we turned the
kickstarter alive
and i was very skeptical of the fact
that you're like listen we're asking for
a lot of money
i'm not sure what's going to happen um
you know if we succeed it's going to be
because at the end of the kickstarter
we we pulled the corpse of this thing
over the finish line by the skin of our
teeth
and you were very optimistic you were
like listen man like i think there's a
bigger fan base out there than you think
they are i think they're going to show
up and show out for you
um you know don't don't discount that
and uh and i was wrong
and you were right is that what you
wanted me to say
yeah that was the point of this whole
[ __ ] story is
i mean whatever happened to you what
happened to you that's fine but
the hero of this story the guy who
believed
um that's right i told mark i was like
look
i see the feedback you know sometimes
during the [ __ ] show
and like you know we kid around about
how mark is is uh
he can be painfully honest sometimes and
uh some people don't kid around about it
they get flat-out angry about it
but i've never seen more appreciation
uh i've always seen more appreciation
way more appreciation than anybody being
like man he always shits on things
people love mark as a storyteller people
love mark's like incision
um insightful thinking into uh
storytelling and this is a free show
that we've been doing for like
a decade or something like that a long
time at this point so
i felt like in a world where like you
know
nobody ever gets taxed you don't tax
anybody
if you you went out there and you were
like hey i want to do a creative thing
i thought for sure that it would [ __ ]
be met with from
our audience at the very least with
nothing but enthusiasm and yes that
turned out to be the case
how quickly did you hit your goal what
did you
think tell them for let's break it down
what was the original goal
the original goal was ninety thousand
dollars
and in doing research onto kickstarter
like what are other short budgets like
you know what if you look at 50 other
stores on kickstarter what they're not
what are they looking for i mean they
were like
10 grand 12 grand 22 grand was i think
that
i'm gonna interrupt you we keep getting
uh on chat people are asking why your
mic is so low you might need to get
closer to your mic or something
it's like right here you are a little
soft are you talking into the correct
side
do you know how to use that thing martin
i'm pretty sure that i do
is this is it's amp boy what the [ __ ]
are you gonna micromanage this from a
distance why am i doing this
bam um oh look who's here everybody
bamfoot and relax
you can probably if you go into your
zoom settings
and up in preferences uh there's
automatic mic
adjustment you may want to turn that off
okay all right
while we're doing that should i put up
mark's kickstarter page
yeah please do of course absolutely is
this better is this warmer is this
louder
it's hotter yeah it's good not hot in a
good way like okay oh like rubbing my
nipples hot that's pretty
excellent sexy hot um the original goal
was how much
the years ago was 90k the first stretch
goal was 110
and the dream stretch goal was 140.
all right so for those of us who've
never done a kickstarter
there's a goal there's a what's the
middle one
um anything beyond the goal is is
stretch goals and you're just literally
it doesn't
unlock anything per se you're just
fragmenting
if we can get this then we get to do
this part if we can get this we get to
do this much
more but we're hoping for the production
fundage
of 90k which kids i will point out is
over three times
the amount of clerks like there was a
reason mark
was like a lot of [ __ ]
scratch right there so 90k and
and how long did you have to earn that
like uh
you have a month you have a month to
earn you know to for your campaign to
run you can set it to
lesser and more time but we set it for
30 days and it's all or nothing like if
you if you get 89k
and don't make your 90 then that money
goes away um
so it's you gotta you gotta win this
race otherwise
you know there's there's a set of steak
knives for second place
um murphy sang as elvis presley back in
the day we gotta win this race
lemonade
[Laughter]
frozen drink um so yeah
we we launched at 12 30 um last
wednesday in the morning 12 30 a.m
yes so i launched it you know close to
midnight as i could
fell asleep woke up you know just
already like 10 grand in the kitty
15 grand in the kitty by the time i woke
up
and the next six hours or so
after i woke up were uh were the most
surreal six hours
ever because i i went to work like i was
in the writers room all day so i
couldn't
i couldn't be monitoring it my sole
pieces of input about how this
kickstarter we're doing was doing
came from kevin i i wish you'd told me
that i thought you were watching it like
i was so i was just hitting you casually
going it's here
it's here away and i assumed he was like
i know bro i'm watching it but i didn't
know that you weren't watching
i was in the dark it's like i was on i
was running silent on a submarine
every time i kind of came up for air
there was a new bit of information about
how i was doing and it came from you and
from danny fernandez
who were both kind of like how you doing
holy [ __ ] it's here oh you're five grand
away man holy [ __ ]
yeah it was watching it go was like holy
[ __ ] like
i remember you like texted me
when you woke up or whatever to be like
hey my shit's up
and i said hit me with a link hit me
with a twitter or whatever the [ __ ]
and before i i put it up fast but then i
was like i want to make sure that i
[ __ ] donate because i don't want
people being like oh you'll [ __ ] tell
us to donate but you didn't donate you
and i couldn't [ __ ] ugh what a long
story one of my credit cards was dead
and i couldn't
it took me [ __ ] 10 to 15 minutes to
log in
finally like you know i i just
i got there but regardless i put down my
loot and i felt like you know
all right this is a nice like chunk
where
he you know he won't have to worry about
like [ __ ] the next two hours or
something like that i thought i was
donating enough
that would cover like a little bit of
time
it was a drop in the bucket like it just
went
so [ __ ] fast and
mark hit his goal it in at what time how
14 hours 14 hours total we funded out
now did you get to go to the second goal
um yeah i mean the minute it never stops
like the campaign just keeps on rolling
and then it becomes you know trying to
incentivize people to
keep donating because at least i know
for myself
i put enough money to make the thing
happen then great my work here is done
gang i'm moving on
but the idea of like if we if we get to
110 then we can start covering visual
effects if we get to 140
we can cover all the the scoring and the
sound and the post production the
editing and the color timing and
all the stuff that goes into not just
making it
you know edited it editing it but making
it as shiny as you possibly can
the first goal is getting in the can the
last goals are just making it look great
and so i started adding more rewards
it's like reward tiers began
disappearing like there was one of the
tiers
was i will i will read whatever you have
and give you an hour-long one-on-one
zoom note session
like send me you know 100 pages or less
send me a screenplay
send me the first 100 pages of your
novel send me an episode of tv send me a
pitch
send me a comic book whatever it is i'll
read it and we'll talk about it for an
hour
um and that goal vanished there were 20
i think i left for 20 backers on that
goal and it went away in like three or
four hours
um and it's like okay this is awesome
but now we need a new thing to put in
there okay so we'll do a shorter version
where we'll get on for half an hour and
you pitch me your idea and i'll give you
feedback on it
because i'm running out of time in the
world for me to read
more and more and more it's like that's
that's going to take me
a week to read all of this material and
then schedule times to talk so
it's a way for me to do a live i'll do
it that way and then we just added
uh the members of the castle to do like
little cameo videos
that they can all um put in for so
tiffany and trisha and you today
are all gonna do like 10 cameo videos
and personalized greetings they'll say
whatever you want to say they'll
wish you happy birthday they'll leave
your outgoing voicemail message anything
you want
it's up there for that you know some
burrito in chat is suggesting
uh he said if i'm not mistaken mark
worked with tit mouse
on the critical role animation um i did
i did i wrote an episode of that if so
he needs to make a call out to all the
critters
apparently tip mouse's like their
little monsters are critters that's what
i'm getting from this
for critical role fans the critical role
fans are called oh that's what it is
critter
that makes more sense he said you need
to do shout out to all the critters for
your kickstarter
because they show up hardcore that's his
suggestion
that's a fine suggestion i think i will
i will hit them up for that
have you learned a thing or two about
marketing and the way way i mean mark it
in
typically branded copyright trademark
kevin and mark um you know it sounds
like in a world where they were like
we're out of this
what else can we put in you know it's
some people look at kickstarter and go
like oh [ __ ] free money
nothing about this is free like you just
heard the man has now committed
his time and you're like oh [ __ ] time
at least he's got money but it's like
in order to satisfy the people who are
putting money into this thing
mark has to do the work he has to listen
to their pitch and process and give them
their time and stuff like that
so it ain't nothing's free in this life
kids like you know
it's it's everything and i'm not saying
it's costly in his [ __ ] soul but it's
like
he's he's gonna have to pay for all this
one way or another
but the nice thing is right off the bat
so much love and support belief in him
as a storyteller that people were like
look
here oh yeah it's just
money on i mean mark is as rich as
robert kirkman right
not that [ __ ] robert kirkman money we
all dream about
yeah it's the the robert kirkman at two
o'clock in the morning rolling over in
his bed
that's the kind of robert kirkman like
that's i made what he makes doing that
no he was like oh what's this and he
found [ __ ] yeah
140 grand um
all right where is it at right now um
now i think jc just had it up i think
it's at 141
000 which means we've we've made it to
our
quote unquote wildest dreams section of
the kickstarter which is
never in a million years thought that
we'd get to the point where everything
we needed
is going to be paid for wait the [ __ ] so
wait what was everything you need
what what was the like the drop dead
what was the we can now afford cocaine
and hookers
money uh 140. 140 gets us everything
140 above 140 and we're above 140 it
gets us
post it gets us music it gets us you
know a live
orchestra of however many people bear
wants to assemble for this
and you want bear with the live
orchestra he's doing that for masters of
the universe
and [ __ ] is exquisite yeah
yeah it's phenomenal and so work with
the same live orchestra to bring that to
life
so knock on wood um
knock on everything god you're so it's
not even like you're like okay in the
fall
i have to do another one because we have
to do our post you are now fully
financed
up the water everything we could have
wanted and so now everything
any more money we make now is literally
to just pay people more
you know and to and to treat them a
little bit better and so that craft
services gets to be better like people
who might have taken a break
in in in agreeing to do this okay
usually i charge x but for you i'll
charge y now i can pay the max i can pay
them what they're worth i can pay them
you know a living wage and then the more
we get the more goes back to those
people
i don't make a dime on this like i'm not
paying myself anything right right
another illusion for some people outside
like oh you
get all this free money he didn't you
didn't build the salary in for yourself
the budget or anything as a writer as a
director nothing
no and i don't know he gets to make the
[ __ ] thing he sees his dream
realized thanks to the being lofted on
the
the wings uh of the
audience
why do i sound more soulful than you
because you went for it
i was going a little i was keeping it
tight
let that be a lesson and also not a good
lesson to
put up there for your investors where
you're like i didn't go for it
i phoned it in
also i figured you needed the soul after
admitting to playing the whitest board
game in the history of the world
you ain't kidding bird bird [ __ ] i think
abercrombie and fitch just called me
do an ad for next week's show
how do you feel did you was it i
imagined it
through the uh perception of our
audience because i know mark
to be an amazing warm uh lovely human
being
some people are like man he's merciless
with
the [ __ ] things he talks about for
those people i'm sure they saw you
reaching your goal
as you know the grinch's heart growing
three sizes or ten sizes
how did you feel watching all this
unfold
it uh it's it's been a roller coaster in
lots of different ways
um you know it's it has not been the
easiest past month um
is you know where my my daughter's
autistic as i've talked about a bunch of
times
the beginning of the pandemic we
discovered she was also epileptic
which tons of fun epilepsy is
um and so she's been on a medication for
the last
11 months or so that it turns out now
that she's at her full dosage it's been
a very slow build to get her where she
needs to be
there's been a series of resultant side
effect behaviors
that have made things incredibly
difficult at home like
nobody's sleeping as much as they want
to nobody's kind of
the stress is very high you know school
has become
difficult because her attention is is un
unable to be directed
and like last week this week was the
zenith of this
where it had just sort of hammered and
landed on everybody
and so to have this be
the wednesday that i had this like kind
of
unbelievably unprecedented outpouring
of emotion and belief and support
to come at the time when i needed it the
most like i could not have planned for
this
um you know wouldn't have wanted this
confluence of things to happen at the
same time
but the fact that it did made you know
it
it got to be difficult to not be crying
at my desk
just watching the the response while
then having to not betray that emotion
at my job
because like they don't know that i'm
launching the kickstarter they don't
know any of this [ __ ] like i'm just
showing up for work and like trying to
make up dumb stories
and you know in another window it's dude
like you just made 90 grand in 14 hours
you know and and just the feedback from
twitter and the feedback from
the comments and the feedback from
facebook and you know both people i've
known for years and people i've never
met
um saying how much they believed in me
um was uh i i don't really have the
words for it beyond uh
like big time thank you because i just i
i needed it more than i knew that i
needed it um
and so for it to for it to manifest the
way it did
is you know it's it's the end of a movie
for somebody else's life
the beginning of this movie from mine
nice
always nice to have a win uh
nice to have a [ __ ] substantial
win mega win particularly like in a week
where you're like
oh [ __ ] i could use it and stuff that is
absolutely [ __ ] tremendous and more
importantly
you're gonna make your [ __ ] movie man
i'm gonna make my movie but now i have
to make my movie
like it's the it's the easy part
so wait when will you shoot um you know
now that it's not theoretical anymore
now that like we know we're doing this
um it was always supposed to be fall
early winter because we were trying to
play the waiting game on covid we were
trying to make it so that
if if we don't have to mask everybody if
we don't have to
cordon people off if we don't have to
have various zones on a set
and we don't have to individually wrap
everybody's food if if
the disease is enough in retreat that we
can have a
normal pre-pandemic production it would
be better
um and it's just those who are like why
cost number one uh as somebody who's
putting together a
movie budget right now we
you know there's about a half a million
dollars cost
because of covid that never existed
before and don't matter what the size of
your production
is that covet piece is a is a big chunk
so for you know a
short film production they don't want to
have to spend
25 30 of their budget on
covet protocols they didn't have a lot
of cash to begin with
and stuff and so every dollar counts and
whatnot so yeah that's
that's kind of a [ __ ] but that would
make sense the longer they wait
mark's banking on the fact that we'll be
you know maybe they lift these
restrictions that are required
because you know it's not like when we
made clerks we were in a convenience
store we weren't
guild we weren't having guild actors or
you know [ __ ] nobody knew what we
were doing
mark is going to be working with
professionals who are members of [ __ ]
sag and so
their representatives are not going to
let them go near a place
unless they can guarantee their safety
and whatnot so hopefully yeah you get to
a place where by the fall
you know they're like oh i don't care
lick the handrails again we don't give a
[ __ ]
opidid's dead cole bid's dead and so
then that don't cost you but my god what
a [ __ ] great
what a great like moment what a great
story what a great beginning
because like yeah where we are right now
yeah you know and it's it's
the thing of it is is that to do this
work you know you know it as well as i
know it that to be a creative person
trying to make that that is a job you do
as a profession you chase
requires an inordinate amount of belief
in yourself
in the face of ultimately every
bit of outside um knowledge you have to
believe you can do it you have to want
it you have to and you can't ever
flag in that otherwise you'll never do
it um
and so i have that belief because you
know i'm a [ __ ] who decided he wanted
to make television for a living
and it's an incredibly hard you know
road to hoe
but you have to believe that you can do
it the thing that i did not
take into consideration that other
people would believe in me
as much as i believed in me and that's
that's the bit that just
that knocked me to my core that like
kind of had me you know
huddling in the corners like slowly
shaking and crying
because that that level of belief is not
a thing that i'm accustomed to
and so to be greeted so warmly with
evidence
um that proved me wrong um was
was the most wonderful thing well i
don't want to take the bloom off the
roads but i got money in this production
too i'm one of the backers and i'm going
to let you know right now i'm a harsh
producer
i'm hard you read those stories about
scott rudin and [ __ ] you think he's a
harsh producer
i'm gonna be calling you texting you
every moment of the day being like why
is this cost this why is this happening
why a plane mark does it have to be a
plane
it's like where's kevin well he went to
the apple store to buy a bunch of phones
to throw at people
[Laughter]
and i bring my assistant i'm like julian
hand me a phone to the remark
um that is no that is that is [ __ ]
phenomenal it's so uh beautiful that it
happened and
beautifully expressed um i'm gonna bring
up
who was it uh who wrote this this is
pretty good
um i don't know how it goes i guess this
one was first
uh the cash d says how much do we need
to pledge
to get victor garber as an extra
splinter and then on top of it
smith posted let's get mark to 300k
so he can hire victor garber and annoy
kev
just for the record that would not annoy
me
that would put me one step closer
interviewing
victor garber which is all i'm
interested in that's the dream
i'm not trying to cast the man i know
he's far beyond the likes of me but
if i could just talk to the man he won't
even talk to me so if mark got him in
his
in the show that's a big win for all of
us yes then then we we're doing a
podcast from the set
hey garber mark's mending bridges that
who knew they were even burnt
remember somebody asked me it's like hey
so are you gonna cast
kevin as an extra in your movie i was
like no
because the problem with extras are
you're not supposed to notice them
so here we are and like a bunch of
people
and then is that kevin smith i'd be like
i know how much money i put into this
production
i'm wearing this hat
there's me in the plane playing sleeping
man
they're like hire him make him an action
don't give him any lines
[Music]
and i keep sleeping so differently in
each shot it's impossible to edit
what are you doing over there man oh my
god [ __ ] it with your movie
on purpose on an editorial level
um man oh man that's [ __ ] uh dope um
so you'll mark will be updating us with
more the
the kickstarter is still wide open if
you look at
anything you heard today and he heard
you heard that it's like
it's not like the more he gets the more
he keeps the more
like poor tricia helfer who's like what
am i doing this for free
[ __ ] you know podcasting enough
she'll break she gets broken off a piece
she gets paid for her [ __ ] work
indeed you know then the camera crew
gets to be a little bit deeper then you
can start to have like second ads
and all the gaffers you need and the
sound crew gets to be bigger and like
just
every everybody gets to make what they
should make and we get to actually fill
it out with people who can
even learn a bit on the job like i'm
totally happy hiring people who are like
hey i've never
shot an avengers movie but i i've got an
eye
or i've got a skill or i've got a taste
and so yeah come on in let's go make
something
and that's what we're getting paid to do
again i know it's linked all over and
[ __ ] but what if somebody's driving and
they're like i must do it on my phone at
80 miles an hour
quickly um i would go to uh to
kickstarter.com
and search for splinter short i think
it's probably
very quickly from the morning first
morning i do it and now i play it
look who's here banff boy uh it's also
on the youtube
uh youtube description so it's
bit.ly slash splinter dash
short so you can get that get it there
as well
um well done bam boy yeah and you know
the one last thing that we're adding to
the campaign
which i i was going to make a big
announcement once we hit the 140k but it
turns out that we did it like while we
were on the air
is now we're going to do a uh a
companion podcast that goes with it that
spins
it's scripted it's not non-fiction so
phil lamar
is going to be one of the voices um
reika sharma is going to be the other
voice
and it's a sort of two or three episode
20 minutes each episode
story that spins out and feeds into the
short itself so it's a
it's sort of a prequel sort of a
companion piece sort of a like what if
you could
what if you could turn the camera over
here what would you see that's what this
is so that and that will be a reward
that every backer above the 25
tier will just get like you don't have
to bid anymore for it like it's just
literally it'll show up in your email
box once it's done
ad vaccin uh is asking a question that i
i
you know i was gonna i thought i knew
the answer but i don't know
will you rent an actual plane
um there are places especially in la but
i assume they exist in most other
production hubs
that specialize in in airplane
production
um there's uh especially here in los
angeles there's three or four
and so the hope is to be able to use
their standing sets
for things like the cockpit and the
galley and what have you to
modify a couple of them for some of the
pieces that are going to feel a little
bit more custom
but we don't have to rent a whole plane
we don't have to build the whole plane
ourselves we just have to sort of modify
what they've already got
um but that's that is where the bulk of
the cost is coming from the
lion's share the largest percentage on
the pie wedge of our budget
is is look is securing the location and
those sets
um yeah pete places out here because you
know
[ __ ] nobody wants to carry a plane
set
unless you have a show set on a plane
why you know you're rarely on it
so they have fuselages that you rent out
and [ __ ] like that and they're like a
quarter
yeah it's not even it's not even a fake
whole plane it's just a section of a
plane
so you're gonna have to i mean yeah the
whole thing's set on a
plane i think that i the person
um who was like is he gonna run a plane
like
like me for a second there was like uh
oh my god is he gonna
[ __ ] build this plane on soundstage
but like you're not gonna build it
you're gonna go
to a place that doesn't they already has
them you know and they have them in ways
that you can
you can just have half a plane so that
you can shoot right in it the cockpit
will
slice in half so you can shoot down the
barrel and then up the barrel and
um but we're gonna have to do some
modifications to it because the the
the short is set on a private plane that
has been heavily customized
so we got a production designer we'll
have to figure out ways to make it look
um shiny and awesome without making us
spare
shiny awesome money um
i'm telling you man you should put a you
should you should
don't drop my name at all okay reach out
to victor garber's people to find out
what it would cost to get him in there
and put that in
as a as like you know if it's like oh he
don't you know he's a hundred grand a
day
you put in 100 grand bonus stretch goal
just for victor garber yes somebody out
there
might be like oh i'll [ __ ] pay to see
that yeah the garber baby goal
it's like you got ourselves a garber
baby
and then you make sure you include in
the language that he's got to do a
podcast with me
listen i need you for three days on a
set and i need you for two hours at
kev's house
to do a podcast i know it sounds weird
but it's a thing
um right now uh the the pascal bouchard
just said you just passed 143k
god dang it holy [ __ ] you're good uh
ragged company recording says jc
mute your mic we can hear your keyboard
um because neither me or mark are taping
um all right there it is kids [ __ ]
marcus off to the races soaring into the
skies
splinter is uh fueled
by the the uh you know flammable jet
fuel that is you
the fat man beyond audience man well
done patrons
patrons of the arts man and uh but so
wait do you think you'll be done by the
end of the year or
um i i hope we'll be done production um
before my birthday in late november i'm
imagining that to
tie everything else up we'll probably
spill into the top of next year
um and then the hope is to be able to
take it to festivals i mean that's
ultimately
the the outlet for a short there isn't a
huge sales market for shorts
it's changing you know hulu's we get
into program shorts netflix is how long
do you think it'll be under five minutes
under 10.
now we're probably 15 i think you can
make it an nft man
well i could i could nft as well
so it could be that is also a movie just
saying i know a guy
you know a guy who knows some [ __ ]
inside the bomb crypto studio
crypto.jsonbob.com
um well that is fantastic man [ __ ]
what a third act to that like [ __ ] tv
movie
yeah pretty damn sweet
thank you sir um of course that
hopefully the third act of this movie
stops here and not like
the crashing and burning people are
suing
calling lawyers to get out of this
nightmare business because we [ __ ] it
up on set in a dozen different ways
like here's like the bloom of the the mr
holland's opus version
and not the nightmare of like beaufinger
while bullfighter even worked out for
let's just hope this isn't the first act
of behind the music
and then he found cocaine that's
it kids be careful with that garber baby
fund because
gotta go somewhere and it could go up
[ __ ] mark's nose we could get a
different guy all together he'd be like
yeah man [ __ ] i love everything the
film started with such promise
until mark bernardin found cocaine
fell into a power a pile of money and a
pile of cocaine
um all right the let's get to
we got no guess mark was the guest this
week i'm our guest this is great so
uh give it up to our guest mark bernard
we raise our
our waterloo uh water to mark bernard
and say congratulations congratulations
not just to mark mind you
but all the smart people who are like
i'm gonna put some money into this
you're all producers of something
[ __ ] cool
the thousand some odd people who is that
what it was a thousand different people
a thousand different people a little
more than maybe 1100.
and the thing of it is is that like
because i can look and see
who donated everything and and who it is
and there's lots of names that i
recognize and lots of you know people
who i'm like oh thank you so much i'm
going to owe you
you know the whole mess of muffin
baskets by the time it's done
but then there are people that like i've
i've never heard of like the names don't
ring a bell
i i couldn't tell you if i've ever
crossed paths with them but i'm pretty
sure that i haven't
who donated a boatload of money like i
expected boatloads from people that i
like knew but the like rando person
who's swim
swanning in to drop 7 500 bucks on this
was just did somebody buy one of those
the masters of the sky yeah
and you don't know who it wasn't like oh
it's [ __ ] uh
zach stench or something right no just a
name that i don't recognize just came in
and bought the big ticket item
and i just and then happened a couple
times i'm like i don't know who this
person is
but once i find out they're going to be
aggressively hugged
to the point that they're uncomfortable
by it they better have their double
shots like you
pretty much because i'm hooking a leg on
that hug [ __ ]
i'm dropping the lingo talking like a
[ __ ] hollywood player already
um all right let's uh you know what we
got some news uh somebody says
kimberly g85 said over 1200 backers now
1200 people [ __ ] believe in you if
you do that every month
there it is
that's your job right i raised 150k
every month and now i'm rich bill murphy
unless he's uh you know
overestimating because we just got a
little estimate before said 143k
he says you're getting so close to 150
right now
so uh man somebody says their stretch
goal of jeff's
kiss t-shirts mark's gonna raise more
money for his movie
in a quicker time than it took me to get
a jeff's kiss t-shirt to go look
don't don't haunt me reach out to jordan
monsanto she's the brain of the
operation
uh i i think they're being made right
now as we speak i'm pretty sure
i love that jordan somewhere like her
phone's gonna start ringing off the hook
it's like just blowing up
be kind about it it's a [ __ ] sunday
and [ __ ] like that
they're in the process of being made
um but yeah those aren't stretch goals
my friends those are stretch your wallet
over to jay and silabob.com
those are and those are stretchy shirts
they will form hug you like nobody's
business
they're soft they'll be nice you'll like
them when they finally [ __ ] happen
lord knows it's taking a long time
i hear these hacks are going to be
available soon too
but then i asked jordan i was like how
many of those hats you get and like the
number was criminally low
and i was like i've been wearing this
for six [ __ ] months
i thought we were getting 10 000 units
what are you nuts
um all right kids uh mark
before he was you know the [ __ ]
spielberg of kickstarter man the [ __ ]
the abe froman of kickstarter the
sausage king
of kickstarter uh he was just a [ __ ]
news man in the streets man no with a
nose for news
uh every once in a while he likes to
stride down those dark alleys just to
get the old
taste again the old scent of the news
ladies and gentlemen give it up
for mr mark bernard because he's going
to give you up
the news this is a cbd cigarette by the
way
take it away newsman mark um this first
news story
um almost felt like if this is all i got
this week if the kickstarter went down
in flames if nothing ever worked out
this would have been worth it this would
have been worth waking up this week
to hear that john boyega is returning as
moses for attack the block 2. they're
going to attack that block again
attack attack the blockier
um and and john boyega who you know i
always thought rather
kind of i didn't think there was any
accuracy to this but remember when he
got up and he was making a statement
telling his truth but at one point he
was like
i'm probably not going to get any work
after this i was like i don't know
john i i feel like the work's actually
about to increase
i did not suspect it would be for a
attack to block two
so i'm happy for him but i'm happier for
all of us that i didn't know
that was in the cards that we were gonna
get attacked to block two i felt like
that was a
one and done and everyone went on to
other successful things so it's nice to
see them all coming back together
yeah like it's the it's the perfect kind
of sequel
which is one that you desperately wanted
at least i did after seeing that first
movie
but never thought you were gonna get and
you were okay with because the movie
ends incredibly well
it's a fantastic movie if you've never
seen it i can't recommend it highly
enough
but there's a hundred percent more story
there and everybody is coming back
joe cornish who wrote and directed the
original movie is returning
boyega is returning who knows how much
of the original cast is coming back
but it's it's been a decade since they
made that movie since boyega blew up
and became a sort of household name um
and uh
and you're they've made three
[ __ ] star wars movies annually
it's like a couple years so yeah you're
right it would be 10 years since
attacked the block
yeah 2011 was when attack the block came
out and uh and
to return to that and to do that thing
where
it's the same actor and like what is
time done to moses you know he's now a
grown-ass man he's not a child anymore
and to be able to continue that story of
a guy who knows that yeah [ __ ] aliens
exist and me and my friends kill them
all
and i've been it's rambo if you want it
to be like rambo
you know you open up rambo 2 first blood
part 2 and he's in prison
you know for for doing awful awful [ __ ]
mind you um but he's got to get bus
busted out of prison to go and rescue
some people in vietnam like
who's going to bust moses out of jail
and what for
like what kind of alien threat do you
need the alien killer to take on
we're about to find out hell yes um
so very excited about that that was that
was the the
crown jewel in my pre-kickstarter
life this past month so very happy about
that
um similarly i'm happy about the fact
that they are not just making a new
highlander movie
directed by uh john wick director chad
stahlski
[ __ ] henry cavill is going to be the
lead
of the new highlander movie i mean i
know everyone was like come on
or superman and [ __ ] and like that's
fine but like
i i like cameron gavel as an actor i
always did going back to the
tudors i thought he was wonderful stand
out and stuff
you know i thought he was a great
superman but like superman
you can only do so much and he did a
bunch but
you know i was never going to watch
what's the witcher or something
uh but this when they when i heard
number one that highlander i was like
smart i don't know why it's just sitting
there dormant but when they said him i'm
like
come on that's [ __ ] fantastic what a
great marriage of
actor to [ __ ] material and [ __ ] um
yeah man there could be only one
apparently that one is
henry cavill uh and it had been
apparently bandied about in hollywood
for a good long while at one point
ryan reynolds might have wanted to be in
the highlander
director justin lin was also playing
with it but now this seems to be the uh
the the gears are meshing the way you
kind of want them to and it's the
director of john wick
yeah chad stachowski so at the very
least this one happens stand back here's
my hot take right
[ __ ] that john wick is some hell of a
picture
i don't know i don't know if you've seen
this john wick yet mark but
oh my my lord they know how to make
cinema um
yeah give that guy a highlander i mean
here
russell mulcahy i believe is the
director first one now russell mulcahy a
wonderful filmmaker also in our
genre he made the shadow a lot of people
don't like but like
i dug because it was very true to the
shaken version of the
shadow that they'd revamp for dc and
stuff like that
but um you know russell mulcahy
you don't think of him as the john wick
guy obviously
especially because john wick happened
years later but
the guy who you tell me the guy who made
john wick is going to be given the
material of the highlander
yep suddenly i'm like we're going to get
a [ __ ]
insanely kick-ass action-oriented
highlander and you forget
and again i ain't taking anything away
from russell mulcahy i could never shoot
the action that he has shot in the
movies he's made
but think about applying you know
[ __ ] head
all they all got to fight and because
there could be only one and there's some
head cutting off going on and [ __ ]
think about that [ __ ] in the hands of
the guy that did john wick
like i don't care who they cast they
could have cast you know [ __ ] victor
garber i would have been very excited
about that
i say victor garber for the sean connery
role i'm just going to leave that there
for
somebody to explore put into the world
yeah but um
i i'm in i love this yeah who's doing
um i don't know let's see not netflix
i don't believe it's netflix i don't
know if they have
yeah they don't have a movie or a series
a streamer
um it's a movie um if i had to guess it
might end up at
gate only because chad stahlski has done
i mean the john wick movies are lions
gate so he's got some
he's got some friends over there um i'm
not saying he has to be
the kurgan but you gotta
clancy brown's still around you've got
to bring him back to be a kurgan
[Music]
you know what i'm saying like that guy
could still bellow
that immortal line yes there can be only
one
i have something to say it's better to
burn out and fade away
uh man oh man okay chad is telling us
that lionsgate's doing this
that makes sense that's gonna be big
that'll be big and that's something i
would be like i'll go to the movies to
see that
oh let me tell you if they find some way
to [ __ ]
bring back that queen score here we are
we're the princes of the universe oh
[ __ ] so good um it's unclear if he's
going to be playing a new role or if
he's going to be conor mccloud of the
clan mcleod born
i hope it's just a reboot man i hope
he's flat out conor mccloud
i mean you know i know i'm not trying to
say disavow the other ones but we've had
a great run with those movies
and i'm okay with them being like here
you go
you just start over and over yeah yeah
that's not a mythology that i
feel particularly you know and i watched
the tv show that
was on the usa for a bunch of years and
it's good like ducking macau conor
mcleod sure
and was it the like what was the
original highlander's name the actor
christophe lemberg frenchman playing
uh scottishmen and a scottishman playing
a spaniard
because why not who wants to
live forever
remember like it didn't have a huge
theatrical run
it was a home video hit it was like one
of the first home video sleepers where
like
it blew the [ __ ] up so much so that they
went and made highlander 2
colon the quickening years later there
were no plans to make it but it had
become so popular on home video they
were like
we're going for it and sadly it wasn't
the highlander
yeah nothing could be but yeah i think
it's
it probably cost about 15 million
dollars you know maybe
and they spent a million of it just to
give sean connery his nut
and and yeah much like princess bride it
was not a movie that did well in
theaters but completely found its way
on home video and cable and then started
a
a sort of franchise which i'm so happy
they're coming back to
here's their chance to not hire you know
sean connery to play
was he a latin man or italian man or no
he was a he was an egyptian
who uh who then was masquerading as a
spaniard at some point
because of course you're talking about a
business where
john wayne once portrayed genghis khan
yes
juan sanchez villalobo ramirez iii
it was a that was good b it's ridiculous
now that i think about it
but we love them so much um all right
yeah that's the hot news man
what is that what else going on some
people in chat were saying something
about a photo
of taika waititi and and
but not of him of um
thor and valkyrie i don't know if it
bring it back
up chat you guys were talking about it
earlier they're like how come they're
not talking about this
and i was like i didn't know you don't
know what this is
that was a thing man for heaven's sakes
um
anyway what else you got um we we are we
are
going to be up to our necks in dc
animated series
specifically jj abrams and matt reeves
are we teaming with bruce [ __ ] tim
on a new batman keep crusader animated
show
from hbo max and cartoon network
um you know perhaps this is what had
been
sort of floated in the internet before
about getting a reboot of batman in the
animated series
now that you get it right now that you
get tim involved that's kind of what
gives you that legacy
but it is also being billed as a
complete reimagining of the batman
mythology
um according to jj we are beyond excited
to be working together to bring this
character back to telling grossing news
stories in gotham city said abrams
the series will be thrilling cinematic
and evocative of batman's noir roots
while diving deeper into the psychology
of these iconic characters
we cannot wait to share this world
um what i'm reading in the chat is
about taika watiti is not neces
it's not the news we normally carry mark
oh
okay um it's not it's not you know
like [ __ ] untoward or whatever but it
is
number one i you know i don't
if it's true it's like hot but i don't
know if this is
it's not the news i thought there was
something like when they were like
tessa thompson taiga waititi i assumed
it was a
sore thing spoiler snapshot of uh of
love and thunder but this
there's some love and thunder involved
but it's uh
it's not it's not fictional i'll let
anyone who's into the information they
can go
discern it for themselves not our
bellywick to cover
yeah and i'm not casting aspersions on
those who would it's just
we generally don't get into the gossipy
stuff
i i i was mistaken i thought it was more
like oh [ __ ] breaking news on thor and
this is like
breaking news on what could or could not
be
happening down under off step mark
offset fair enough i think uh we can all
read between those lines enough to know
that if it's a thing you want to
discover the internet will tell you that
story
um but we will move on to the other
animated series that
warner brothers uh announced is a my
adventures with superman
show from hbo max and cartoon network as
well jack quaid the
uh the boy who's on the boys indeed
in the center well i love this kid man i
mean he's wonderful on the boys but i
loved him in the show called vinyl he's
real
i like him a lot i just said i love them
and then i downgraded to like i love
this kid
he's playing clark kent slash superman
correct
indeed and what is the premise of this
animated chat it is uh described as a
kids and family animated series
following 20
20 something versions of superman lost
lane and jimmy olsen
as they begin to discover who they are
and everything they can accomplish
together as an investigative reporting
team
at the daily plan i like it i like it
very much
um they didn't announce any other voices
just him correct
yeah he's the only one in the press
release they announced no voices for the
batman show
just a unique take on an updated take on
indeed tim of course coming back um
guy who defined that style how
style for for decades now for heaven's
sakes
he gets to revisit and recreate again
he's done that a few times
with his original designs even within
the run of batman the animated series he
he got like to a place where he's like
no i want to redraw it
yeah let's do something new we've done
this a lot
but uh jj and matt reeves involved in
that one who's involved in superman they
say
um they didn't they didn't release any
any creative auspices
per se but um you know like i'm i'm here
for it like they seem to be leaning in
and exploiting these things in
interesting ways warner brothers is
making more cartoons i don't believe it
yes and they're making still more
cartoons my friend there's more than
that
there's more than that because dwayne
johnson has decided he wants to star as
crypto the superdog in
dc league of super pets
both sign that why not man sure it's sam
levine
show happening without him and then
suddenly he was like i want in or
they announced it all together um i
think it had been happening without him
um but then once you get him it becomes
a
for all sorts of reasons a much bigger
deal yeah no [ __ ] man wow [ __ ] a big job
you know i'm all for a [ __ ] super pet
show and
and he seems like he's such a nice guy
let him play
[ __ ] crypto let him they'd be lucky to
have him [ __ ] pay [ __ ] to play crypto
they'll make crypto by letting him play
crypto yes
um which is apparently a thing that he
will you know take time out of doing
black adam
to shuffle off to a voice booth
do you see that picture he put up on his
instagram of yeah
in the shadows from on set
and the [ __ ] he wrote about it like
whether he wrote it or somebody else but
it's in his feed
like he loves this character man he's
pot committed
very much so yeah he's really gonna
try to make black adam a way bigger
thing than black adam currently is
and yes i think if anyone could succeed
it's
dwayne the rock johnson
indeed if anybody can make fetch happen
it's dwayne johnson
that's hysterical um what else we got
um staying in dc uh in the dc universe
um the batgirl movie finds some non-joss
whedon directors
they did and i i would have put cold
hard
cash money
on it being a female director but i
would be wrong wouldn't i mark you would
be wrong
um it is a pair of gentlemen who
previously did bad boys for life
adil el rb and bilal
fala have been tapped to direct warner
brothers in dc entertainment's batgirl
movie
um christina hudson who did bumblebee um
pen the script she did suicide squad as
well right she did suicide squad as well
um the movie will appear on hbo max i'm
sorry
um uh harley quinn i think she wrote
that
yeah and they had the fabulous yeah yeah
birds of prey that's it sorry
um this movie will appear on hbo max
unclear if it will get a theatrical
release as well but this is part of
their long game
to incentivize people to sign up for the
hbo max
um and yeah joss had stepped off the
project back in 2018.
so wait this is not going to be a
theatrical film batgirl
no no warner brothers and hbo max and
warner media
has decided that i know i know
it seems as though hold on mark i got to
call the mayor of hollywood
what are you nuts well how how how is
this just
a streaming series and not a [ __ ]
like they got wonder woman
they got wonder woman but you know they
like take wonder
throw back take woman off put girl
make the same amount of money like they
could be printing
big [ __ ] dollars that's a billion
dollar franchise handled correctly
yes and you cast it right like oh [ __ ]
and they're just going to let it be a a
serious i'm not i'm not
you know look this wonderful streaming
series i'll [ __ ]
i'll fight anybody who says that hacks
isn't one of the greatest [ __ ]
streaming series of all time now airing
on hbo and i'm not even a paid [ __ ]
advocate i'm just a big fan
but i i would not have taken i would not
have thought they would take batgirl in
this direction maybe a
spin-off animated series sure but that
smelled like a movie to me you know
i mean it was part of this big
announcement that warner brothers made
um i want to say like four or five
months ago
that they were you know post justice
league pose
snyder cut they were examining their
sort of plans and their schemes going
forward
and they were very clear about wanting
to sort of dual track some of these
things it would be the movies that were
absolutely big
time [ __ ] 250 million dollars we're
going to spend we need to make a million
dollars back in
their theaters um we are wonder womans
will live there your batmans will live
there
but then there was a whole other cast of
movies they were making
um that they wanted to do for hbo mags
batgirl being one of them
static shock being an another one of
them
um and the the commentary at the time
was
so you're just gonna put all of the lady
movies and the black movies
on tv but save the big movies
that you think will appeal to everybody
for theaters
um to which a t and t
now quickly trying to shed warner
brothers um
had no real comment on um i agree with
you
back in the day back in the day and i
agree with you like it feels like it's
very short-sighted
he's shy on in the comments section
on youtube said uh batgirl isn't wonder
woman
yes but for for many reasons i agree
with that statement however
you know that girl handled correctly has
a chance
i'd feel like to be a billion dollar
franchise depending on who you cast
you're talking about one of the most
iconic
uh female superheroes from the dc
universe
like you know name
i'm not gonna get into this because the
internet will be like here i'll name 10
others but like
you say dc female superheroes yes wonder
woman checks the box right away that's
probably the first name you
think of i think a batgirl before i even
think of supergirl
you know the suit the cw has done a
wonderful job of building that character
up into a franchise but like
just comic books alone i'd be like oh
batgirl
um i i feel like you know all right
maybe i'm overestimated maybe it's a
half a billion dollar franchise but like
it just feels bigger to me but i ain't
cheating on it it's like this is the way
they want to go great but
you know [ __ ] you cast like the
modern day equip hey all right who's
that girl who sings that song and
everybody love you cast olivia rodrigo
as batgirl it's a billion dollar
franchise right there
yeah billy eilish's batgirl makes you a
billion dollars
make a billion dollars man like the
right casting and the right
filmmakers and the right handling of
that character and stuff like
and you know we're getting closer to
that world where the right things happen
all the time but hey
i'm happy to see any batgirl any [ __ ]
thing so if it's on hbo max
i love hbo max [ __ ] swear by it i
can't
i'm irritated i have to do this [ __ ]
show because i'd much rather be watching
mary
but i'm only doing this show because
mayor of east town won't be on for a few
more hours so
yes i love hbo max but i'm just shocked
that they get you know batgirl before
the movies get back girl
uh we'll see if that changes you know i
i think that they're leaving themselves
a flexibility to shift course if they
want did you see me i'm like we'll see
if that changes and someone
at att is like you're a customer shut up
you don't even know nothing
the customer is always right i was
taught thank you mark yes
what my friends said
um did we discuss that story that att
oh look who's here it's bamf boy ladies
and gentlemen i just wanted to say
you know what to be fair banff man
uh i just wanted to say back when i
would watch
uh batman 66 the adam west batman
and you'd see the little batgirl
cycle at the end of the opening title
sequence
those were my favorite episodes i would
get so excited by that
so batgirl is the boba fett
of the batman universe the like the best
least
best kept secret there is the same way
that somebody and maybe this is what
they're thinking because i was just
about to say the same way they
took boba fett and turned him into a
streaming series that really [ __ ]
like blew the world apart
maybe that's what they're thinking
they're like look we're gonna [ __ ]
mandalorian this [ __ ]
to be fair batgirl never went out like a
punk ass [ __ ]
um and never will and never will
but yes point is very well taken as long
as you skip killing joke and never will
but even on the heels of that she became
awesome yes that's right there was a
huge victory there man
but uh she does have that uh
you know she's got an iceberg in her
story indeed
and i wonder how long they take before
they get to that right
they better not do that if they're doing
a series on batgirl
they're not it's a movie oh really yeah
yeah but they better do
three before they even start thinking
about killing joking it
yes you know or maybe never which would
also be fun that would be fantastic as
well but you know these
cats man they you know this is the story
everyone knows right do that
um i uh look i'm in i want a batgirl
anything and like bamf man who banffed
out of here and [ __ ]
those were my favorite episodes when you
saw the cartoon bat cycle come through
you were like
we're gonna see batgirl so i'm i'm down
like a clown
i got a question here uh let's go let's
talk about that
att thing because somebody chat kabuki
kid
is saying dune is no longer going right
to hbo max
but i saw a different story where hbo
max was like no that's still happening
yeah their plan is their plan it's it
was never not going to hbo max and it's
never not going to theaters
um i think their hope is day and day day
and day
their hope is that if you can reopen at
2 000 screens then more people will go
see it in the movies
and i think that so far the the
dual release pattern is working out for
them
yeah they're making their money and
they've said that they're not going to
do it in 2022 but they're not going like
what a disaster this was
uh kong godzilla really popped for them
in a big bad way where they got the big
boost on hbo max but they also got
the big theatrical boost as well and i
feel like
you know i i you know i feel like
everyone wants dune to be like
that i i don't you know it's got timothy
chalamet so he's a
wild card where everybody could show up
or something like that
but you know kong vs godzilla is just
that screams like i gotta go see that in
the theater if somebody's just like
meditative space opera
some people might be more inclined to
watch it
um the uh what do you what do you think
though um
at t discovery yeah so real quickly for
those who aren't following
that too closely at t bought
warner brothers time warner and you know
it took a few years because the
government was [ __ ] blocking it and [ __ ]
and then finally it came to pass like
three years ago or whatever
and uh now just recently
at a t announced that they are going to
spin off warner brothers into a
uh what do they call that merger
with discovery plus networks
which would make you know this
incarnation of warner media
hbo max discovery plus the
biggest media company on the planet in
terms of sheer holdings is that correct
um something like that i mean i think
that that discovery
their assorted gallery of networks which
includes the science channel
and and it got a lot just like food
network and
they are the largest producer of
unscripted tv whereas
uh unscripted content and warner media
is the largest producer of
scripted content and so putting the
chocolate and that peanut butter
together would make this gigando company
um and 18t the the culture clash between
what was ultimately you know a sort of
cell phone company
um and a media company that makes stuff
never really gelled that well um you
know from an executive
they are responsible for the snyder cut
though correct like left
was warner brothers left to their own
devices you were never going to see that
snyder cut
but yeah i mean he bought warner
brothers and they launched hbo max they
were like we'll go with this this sounds
good let's do this
yeah i mean they they were very much
like they were the drivers behind
the the day and date release of all
warner's theatrical movies
um for 2021 because they they were
trying to amp up
and drive subscribers to the service
which was floundering in the beginning
and so like yeah they they had some
ideas for sure but it was never a
perfect fit
and it seems as if at t was like you
know what
maybe this is more trouble than it's
worth um
three years after we made this big ass
stink about it um
maybe it's it's time to part our ways
and uh and so yeah
discovery warner media whatever that
looks like
provided it passes the antitrust due
diligence by the government
will be a giganto new company that is
going to give you everything
uh under the hood of at least two new
apps
and they've said they're gonna spend
netflix money on content
yes because the the streaming awards are
not even almost over
ooh banff man has something exciting to
say can i pitch an idea for the
discovery hbo max merger
please mark and i are in charge as you
know yes
how house hunters superheroes so we get
a young couple it's like a pet groomer
and
a stay-at-home mom and they go to like
wayne manor
and like get to see the basement of the
bat cave and the fortress of solitude
and we get to watch these people uh
tour superhero homes that they can't
afford
but magically they can are they real or
they're just looking at the sets
no like you do it uh
scripted as like
you you script it as if it was
unscripted
right so like the office so like the
office yeah
okay it would have to be more
interesting than um
the laundry guy which is a show that is
actually on
discovery plus about a dude whose
expertise is every week
what stain can i get out of these
clothes and how difficult is it to do so
i i i mean look that show's not for me
but i get that that would work
like yeah yeah i mean look that could
totally work on youtube right
but like i get that that works in
discovery world where people are like
let me see if i'll get that out of the
shirt oh we did it again
in a six minute clip of like guess what
i did guys
bleach again like how many different
ways
for this to happen i think i we should
also note that
jc came in with a perfectly serviceable
idea
and we actually were like well
how did this go yeah it could have just
been like we're not really in charge of
[ __ ]
you know warner discovery whatever
they're called at this point so
we could have just been like yeah that's
great but instead we were like
we acted like we were literally in
charge of the network that's the same
reaction i get whenever i pitch
something people like
interesting banff like i just want to
i want to call out danny b in the chat
for saying it's the worst idea he's ever
heard
chat's awfully saucy tonight here's
another one man [ __ ]
daniel kay says when has kevin ever been
right
when he says something will make a
billion dollars he's
number one you're right i've always been
wrong number two
how dare you okay
come into my house and tell me that i'm
always wrong
um the uh well
what is this um
what else we got um similarly on the att
shedding one or maybe uh forming a giant
conglomerate of reality plus scripted
amazon apparently is weeks into
negotiations
to buy mgm i've been seeing that
indeed um because ultimately i mean
amazon can make movies they've already
done so they can acquire movies that is
well within their purview
um they can make tv shows they can do
they can do all of the new stuff the
thing
that they don't have is a library
um they don't have a giant pile of
movies that can be a
exploited for things to remake and
reboot and b just exist on their service
in perpetuity that will never go away
because companies like netflix and
amazon
who who don't have that vast library are
always in negotiations
for movies to put on their service which
is why movies disappear from those
services all the time
because the license has come up like oh
hey we had the dark knight it went over
to warner brothers we had transformers
it went back to paramount plus we had
this it's now
gone if amazon buys the mgm library
like for example they
you know the fargo tv show becomes
theirs yeah you know i mean they then
get all the rockies they get all the
pink panthers they get the magnificent
sevens and
four weddings at a funeral they get
every episode of you know stargate and
you know fame and teen wolf and and
that's just all the
mgm stuff then mgm also has a library of
things they've absorbed from
other like other prop for example when
we worked on uh
buckaroo banzai one uh back in the day
that
was an mgm property i was like how'd mgm
wind up with this they were like you
know some
companies folded and wound up with them
so that would mean amazon
would own buckaroo banzai which is weird
because we were set up at amazon
so it's smart they should i mean they
got all the money in the world why not
buy the [ __ ] mgm library
yeah i mean it would be a nine billion
dollar acquisition
which too you know your average person
who tries to raise 90k on kickstarter
sounds like a lot
but um for amazon it's a it is a drop in
the bucket
um because and that bucket is not
necessarily
built entirely upon selling toilet paper
to people
um the thing that i'm not sure the
average person knows
is that amazon's largest revenue uh
generator by far
is web server space um
i think they where amazon makes their
money
amazon yeah i remember going i had a
general meeting at amazon once
um you know meeting some executives
about whatever and
uh and security there is insane like you
know you've got like
fingerprints and you've got a badge you
gotta wear all the time or whatever and
i was like why is the security so high
here it's just friggin amazon
and uh and the person who i was meeting
with said
well it turns out that um the pentagon
uses amazon's web servers
and so we are a hard classified location
that's true i went pitch there and
there's like a government facility like
you need a badge and there's a
gun there and [ __ ] yeah they don't [ __ ]
around because their web servers end up
being used by
almost everybody and like that's where
they make their money
and so they could give a [ __ ] if you buy
toilet paper or watch
lower the rings or whatever else because
they've got
that's where that money comes from i'll
tell you right now
be smart for them to buy mgm that gives
them bond right
for whatever they're charging like bond
alone they'd be able to print
[ __ ] money off of because you could
put bond in a movie theater and put them
on amazon and you'd still
[ __ ] make bank you know they should
do this thing man um
ross ross hasty
in the chat said fun fact
chad stachelski
the guy who's gonna make uh what was he
doing again
uh highlander he was brandon lee's stunt
double
in the crow i didn't know that
that is a fun fact yeah i'm not sure if
it's him or if it's david leitch
um but one of them was keanu stunt
double in the matrix
is that right they met keanu um
and then looped him in for the john wick
of it all
um david uh
uh david ebik ebakim says
warner brothers owns most of the mgm
library
you're not wrong they own a lot of like
for example warner brothers owns
gone with the wind don't they and that's
an mgm
film's got the lion in front of it and
[ __ ] but
you know they don't have everything
they've got some key titles but
those titles mark listed they've you
know they've got the rockies they've got
the the uh yeah the panthers stayed
i mean bond is complicated because the
broccolis chocolate family has
that controls it um but mgm has the
right to produce it and then mgm because
they didn't have theatrical
had always dealt with sony um at least
recently double sony is the distributor
but yeah they've got some 4000 movies in
the library and that is not
that's not a thing to sneeze at
[Music]
um justin bernstein said they would also
get the mgm resorts is that true
i don't know like amazon would suddenly
be in the casino business as well
we are getting closer and closer to them
being that [ __ ] company in wally
everything yeah [ __ ] they cover a lot of
ground man
um our last new story for the week
is that uh sort of buried in
an investor presentation um
from lucasfilm is that star wars ranges
of the new republic
the show that they had announced last
december
that was presumably going to star gina
carano and carl weathers
this is not the uh the the patty jenkins
show
correct not petty champions rogue
squadron is the patty jenkins show
the road the squadron was one shell and
what was the other one the acolyte
was um that's the leslie headline show
that's the sith
kids show right but what was this show
with the
rangers rangers of the new republic that
is separate from
rogue squadron correct wow i
they got to do better because i thought
that was a [ __ ] thing
i mean you know i know they don't have
to sell it right now but in my head
that was one project all right so patty
jenkins thing is
still going on that's rogue squadron and
what news on this
the news on this is that it was
announced um as part of their giant
rollout where we saw that they were
making an asakutano show and the acolyte
with leslie hedland and the kenobi was
going to be up and running
um that this was going to be sort of
spun out of this episode
of the mandalorian the second season
where cara dune is now a ranger
and and carl weathers they were kind of
like walking off in the sense that we're
gonna have crazy adventures aren't we
yes um that show is now no longer
happening it is not in
active development at disney plus
anymore
also chad is yelling at me to say that a
rogue squadron
is a movie not a show
this other thing rangers was going to be
a series it was going to be a serious
yes
um well chat is doing a better job at
conveying information to a star wars fan
than star wars itself because i didn't
um yeah that show ain't happening
anymore well the show's not happening
lucasfilm apparently has no desire to
recast
cara dune um which seems a little
short-sighted because it was a cool
character and
if you've got the promise of more story
just [ __ ] recast they do it all the
time like there's at least four
different people on game of thrones
who showed up as one actor and then the
next time you sell them was another
actor
yeah that did happen a few times yeah
and ultimately nobody cares
um but uh what we should also shout out
nobody said it here chap but i remember
this from earlier oh somebody just said
it in chat
um dave filoni got a promotion this week
speaking of star wars they made them
they got the big job they call them some
title oh
man so i guess the felony promotion
happened
last summer and they just got around to
updating the website
and then twitter saw the website update
and went crazy
is it is the backstory on that but
but he is apparently people
yeah hey did you know that rangers of
the
republic was a series and rogue squadron
was a movie and that they were two
different things
yeah rangers was kind of in the like
spoken to money of those cbd
rangers was going to be in the like
filoni
favro universe of like ahsoka and
rangers mandalorian book of boba
and then patty jenkins had her movie
kind of separate how goes that movie is
that still happening
i know nothing of the movie but
you know everything well i'll i'll give
two ideas that tie into each other
uh bad batch this week which three
people in chat asked me to talk about so
here i am um is uh
had fenik shaun who was
boba fett's friend in the mandalorian
the one that in season one got shot
and then she had the the robotic abdomen
yeah was in bad batch this week so maybe
maybe they've given up on cara dune
because they're like well we've got this
bounty hunter and bounty hunter show
seem to be doing
real well and the the actress who plays
her is like a huge star wars fan and
doesn't cause trouble on the internet
maybe we should do something that would
be my guess
is give her a show um and she's in bad
batch
uh this week which the episode was
called
cornered and in general
not are you talking about ming now when
ming na when
yes from agents of shield you keep
talking about her like
you're like this actress you know the
baby wakes up for 3 a.m feedings and my
brain is not quite where it used to be
don't you throw your
baby under the bus
so uh veteran actress worked for like 30
years in hollywood
i know and i'm sitting there going who's
he talking about because he
he would have just said ming not wanting
to be talking about it
i you know i just watched bad bad it's
all i have
i have this much every time i think of
something i lose a bit of star wars
knowledge
so true what's your
she was like standing next to him so
she'll be in
uh book of boba fett assuming so here
was
here's what my big takeaway from this
week's bad batch was
which was uh omega who's the little girl
who joined the bad batch
um they have to stop on a planet for
supplies
and she goes off and
uh fenix and shows up and is trying to
claim a bounty on her
and in the previous episodes i
you're led to believe that the uh
kaminoans
the cloners have put out the bounty
to bring her back but i think the
the real cool thing would be is if
boba fett has actually put out the
bounty
on omega because omega would be
boba fett's sister if boba fett
is the biological clone of django
and omega is a experimental or
failed clone the only female clone
i would think that boba fett who was
just trained
uh a handful of years ago by aura singh
in the
in the clone wars and is now working
with
boba with boba fett is now working with
fennick
in the book of boba fett why not set
up that relationship in bad batch
so boba hires fenix sean
to reunite him with his sister if what
you're saying is true
it still doesn't even mention the fact
that ming now was [ __ ] mulan dude
she was move on as well
talking about her like she's some random
i hear this actress as a big star wars
fan
how adorable this is like isn't she one
of the only people in the world there's
like
a like disney princess
uh marvel character she's agents of
shield right
yep and also now a star wars
like she's like got that rosario triple
thing going on like the egot
of
the nerd god uh man her performances
mulan is one of my favorite animated
performances
of all time um
remember when she's like get off the
roof get off the roof get off the roof
and she whips that [ __ ] shoe at
the head of what's his name of shan of
shenyu
now you make me want to watch the og
moulin
and there's look with all the with all
due respect to
the live action there is only one
version of mulan for me my friend
a lot of people pointed out that uh hey
man that's perhaps not the most
culturally appropriate version of the
story with the little eddie murphy
dragon in it and stuff like that
but i like that's my mulan
you can't take her away from me and you
never will i'll die on the hill of that
milan thank you very much
oh i will too man come on that's what
any murphy's
like greatest [ __ ] performances
where's like the powerful the
pleasurable
it's the shoulder shimmy that sells that
one oh my god it's so good because he
just does the pleasure
and he's getting that shadow they have
him like shadowed up
and you one lucky bug him and crickey
and remember they do batman and robin at
one point
he's like citizen who are you is like
your worst nightmare and they did
like batman a batman reference in the
movies
at a time when nobody was doing batman
references like
you know the batman movies had [ __ ]
died and all of a sudden mulan made this
like wicked [ __ ] batman reference
[Music]
i remember being seen when i saw that
movie mark
like you and a bunch of asian girls
were like representation right yeah
i was like right and they're like how
are you and i'm like well the batman
thing it took a minute but we got it
yeah i mean you guys go first i get it
but i gotta be back here with batman
uh i came freddie murphy but i stayed
for ming now when that's what i'm there
you go
um the uh all right
that's uh you know it's it may be the
end of the news but we should uh
honor the the dead charles groton
yes the great charles grubbing and it
doesn't matter
what your favorite charles grodin
performance is a lot of people of course
rightfully cited midnight run
um i love midnight run i paid to see it
in the [ __ ] theater
it was a sleeper hit because of people
like me
yeah i'll take a little credit um but i
loved him in
uh neil simon's uh seems like old times
which
i was forced to watch many times as a
kid because my
parents liked it my brother and sister
liked it
this young kid you know i had chubby
chase so i was kind of there for it but
they it was like early days of cable
they would run that [ __ ] like
beastmaster
so i saw it so many times and you know
he had he had the straight man roll he's
got the tough job but he even pulled it
off with the plum
he was great and heaven could wait he
was [ __ ]
charles growing was fantastic and
everything for a lot of people he's
beethoven
uh i passed those dog movies myself and
stuff
he didn't begrudge the man his right to
be in the indeed
great muppet caper for a lot of people i
saw on twitter it was about that was
their first access point to him that to
me i'm not sure you know
i'm not i'm not here to raise or lower
the muppet movies but
as someone who you know i didn't pay to
see those in the theater because my
parents paid for me
to see him in a theater i preferred the
muppet movie
that that being said charles grodin is
wonderful in in the great muppet caper
yeah he's told everything he was in man
he was ever bad he was great as a talk
show guest
just trying to ice david letterman at
any chance he got
um how old 86.
uh also mr paul mooney passed away this
week
indeed negro thomas himself
um going further back uh
you know the very famous richard pryor
snl sketch
that helped define that show was written
by
mr paul moon um and if you've never
seen um his stand-up like
dive in it's it's really good stuff he
was not he was in the 70s it felt like
he had a massive heart attack i think
yeah what happened to charles grodin
just um i think it's natural causes i
didn't see
anything it was mid-80s or something
yeah they put up a picture of him and i
was like surely that's charles rhoden's
dad and then i realized
i haven't seen him in 30 years you know
and people age and stuff but also
charles grodin
wore like a piece for most of his career
i remember correctly like i think or
maybe i'm confusing his character and
the lonely guy i just remember at one
point
that like somebody was like oh no he
wears
like you know a hairpiece or something
like that
i think the last time we should be
talking about as we honor the man's
final days we're like he wore a
hairpiece i think
right the first time i saw him was on
louie
yeah he was on yeah he's been he works
continued to work with steph but
absolute legend always great um
which is a perfect place is annie to say
that that's the end of the news
my friend that is the end of the
official news i could share a little
news with you in as much as then i
shared it uh on twitter
i saw episode the final episode of uh
uh part two of uh
our masters of the universe
and it is wonderful
it it has some of them like it's crazy
[ __ ] full of action
just with every
i can't with every he-man every version
of a he-man fight you've ever wanted to
see
it is chef's kiss
jeff's kiss if you keep it on brand
uh to our directors uh pat and adam who
i talked about last week as well
um it is it's it's just great
i can't wait to share more
and more is is coming i'm not allowed to
say when or i'm not allowed to say what
but
i've seen a schedule and things are
things are moving forward kids
they are indeed yeah you're gonna ah
i can't i don't want to get in trouble
the most fun that i had
um when we were watching the the first
chunk
um last week at your house because i
remember leaning over to eric carrasco
and i said
i wrote a line and mark hamill said it
and it's the dumbest [ __ ] line i
can't believe
it made the cut i remember when it
happened
like even when it was an animatic i sent
it to you to just be like because
it was such an original line
i protected that line all the way
recorded
and mark loved it mark thought it was
really funny
but it works too it's such a throwaway
like i can't believe mark hamill just
said that yes
yeah yeah it's crazy um people are in
chat they're like we want mo too it's
it is oh it's well we know when it's
coming now
it's july 23rd but you're
you're gonna you're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna feed your eyes prior to that
kids
yes yes that's all i'll say about that
um okay well we're done with the news
give it up for mark he found us some
[ __ ] news unless anybody in chat has
some news they want to throw at us that
we forgot i think we
really oh [ __ ] people asked about uh
modok we didn't watch
i didn't watch modoc yet did you i
haven't seen it yet either they sent me
a kit though
ooh not good let's do a little show and
tell well first off
this got sent a while ago and uh we
never got to it i never got to it
um he certainly never needs our help but
um our good friend brad
meltzer uh wonderful comic book writer
wonderful writer
like [ __ ] tv show isn't he on a
discovery or a history show or something
it's like brad melcher's decoded or
something to that effect
always working and he does these uh
ordinary people
change the world books like this one is
the i am frida kahlo book he does these
with
christopher ileopolis we've we've talked
he's been on the show we've talked to
him before and so
he had he sent this thing uh says dear
person who we love
this is the only book i ever dreamed i
literally woke up
with the idea fully formed i know that
sounds nuts
when i woke up that morning i remember
thinking that's an actual story and it
was
sunday quits just like that then the
other days of the week hold
tryouts for a new day from there we got
caldecott medal winning artist dan
santat to draw it
and we were off and running as for
sunday you'll see exactly why she quits
and if it's a reason that so many of us
can relate to today
in the end this is really a book about
kindness and proof that if you show that
kindness to others
every day could be a new day so if you
like the book it's out march
2nd so we're you know [ __ ] two months
beyond that
please tell somebody the book is
entitled a new day
wow that premise wanted a new day must
be relaxing tranquil
chill though not as chill as saturday
healing blessed
blessed replenishing quiet committed and
most important must be able to give
people
good dreams and get along with others so
yeah apparently the plot is sunday quits
and they look for a new day to replace
sunday
and um spoilers mark i'm gonna guess
[ __ ] works out
it's a kid's book but it's beautifully
rendered um
you know looking at that cover it looks
as if it's just a pixar movie waiting to
happen
oh no [ __ ] man that's why i wanted to
bring it up because when
meltzer makes that kirkman money i want
to be like i was there bro
ground zero i helped you build a new day
um no it does it looks like a pixar
movie waiting to happen
and then it came with uh make the most
of your
days with a new day so one a calendar
with a little marker that right on wipe
off
that's adorbs but meltzer is like one of
the
genuine good guys out there and this is
a genuinely [ __ ] inventive
concept so we send him our love we send
him our support two months [ __ ] late
but in any event that was sitting on top
of this
we got a package from aim mark
from advanced idea
mechanics isn't it like a good acronym
one of these promo boxes they send out
to be like watch the show and i'm like i
was gonna anyway
look at this [ __ ] bomb
up here it says you have been recruited
to aim
now let's take over the world through
mad science
and they send you [ __ ] so i'll dish out
the [ __ ] and tell you what it is
dear new recruit you've been recruited
to defend the
whatever league against the codex
uh this is a aim cup you know a
hot or cold cup travel cup that has a
modoc
at the back um this
is a aim stress ball good
this is a
well it looks like a a
can cozy a modoc can cozy
that's an excellent idea for a koozie
let's see if we can test it out right
now
oops easy there killer
oh why thank you
now if only it levitated up to your face
oh that'd be amazing
i mean you know they tried what the [ __ ]
um so it comes with the cozy as well it
comes with this book
why hello beautiful hello my wife just
showed up ladies and gentlemen she's
still feeling it from all my bird jokes
the other night
even the reference to us yes
i'm telling you them bird jokes they pay
dividends my friend
uh you're next with your beak oh [ __ ]
i'm writing that one down that's good
uh this is a uh welcome new recruit
aimbook and it's just an empty
notebook so you can write some [ __ ] in
it which is good like why to send
something useful
and then over here you got a lanyard
uh badge uh but it just
it has a modoc picture and it says on
the back what he is and what not
it's essentially a hulu ad and uh
this aim card says so you've decided to
join aim
of course you have there's no greater
honor
than dying in the name of and then they
cross out working for moda
we at aim believe in changing the world
through science by conquering it
as an ancient game you will build
anti-matter laser cannons
learn to turn people into dinosaurs or
maybe turn dinosaurs into people and
occasionally
be forced to uh massage my hover chair
sores oh my it goes on and on it's very
funny jokes and stuff in any event
that is the complete package
that's i mean i gotta i want to find out
how much
one of these costs in one of the boxes
i mean it's you know the the cup let's
say the cup's like
499 tops the ball is like a buck
can cozy's like a buck you know this
costs maybe a buck to throw together i
guess the contents are
you know 10 to 20 bucks max and then the
the designer box
itself it just seems like like i
appreciate it thank you and keep sending
this stuff
but like long way to go to a pre-sold
guy
you know what i'm saying like i was
watching this regardless
um but any event thank you to the good
folks at hulu or whoever sent us
the cool modok swag i will be watching
it
um that was when you know that show was
born around the same time as the
ill-fated howard the duck show
there were four of us there before hulu
marvel cartoon shows that
um uh were going to be
and it was modoc was the first one they
were the furthest along
then there was uh hip monkey
there's nothing chimp hit monkey i think
it is
um that's still happening and then both
of them were gorgeous
like you know stunning recreations or in
you know takes on their material and now
we see what modoc looks like and it
looks expensive to me
um and the the the other one hit monkey
or hit chimp
assassin shim god damn it i can't
remember i want to say hit monkey
that looked like kill bill and it was
just crazy good
then the other two shows were uh dazzler
and
tigra which was going to be
um the comedian with the show
um who used to be on comedy central now
she's on netflix
um i don't know chelsea handler
there it is with her show and i think
hold on bam boy
and then uh and then the fourth show was
was howard the duck um but the
when they did the big move where kevin
foggy absorbed
you know like marv there ain't no more
marvel tv don't go away bam
boy just be patient you [ __ ] ran away
get back here bam boy you don't want my
particular brand of gin then i will take
my god
wait he was like oh i won't be spoken to
then i'm bamfing away
um so that all the the two of them got
dumped uh
the two of them got to live because they
were further down the road or maybe they
were better than ours but i was told it
was because they were further down the
road
and now we're getting to see that that
one so i feel long story short uh that's
just my way of saying like i'm not
saying i feel any sense of authorship
but a sense of kinship
with this modoc show cause i remember
going all those pitches
um with the hulu folks and just being
like you know [ __ ]
man the modocs got us all beat just
because it looked like fantastic
um so i look forward to watching it and
we thank them for the [ __ ] that they
sent us
when we start doing live uh fat man
beyond back at the cantina when
jc lets us all come back in when the
state says it's kosher
there'll be lots of this [ __ ] coming
your way kids
june june 15th they reiterated in
another
some sort of governmental post
june 15th so after that we'll be able to
have real shows again
why did you come to our rescue banff man
and then
and then abandon us something that only
one batman ever did between two sequels
and that was because he lost his
girlfriend if we remember correctly
uh i was just gonna give you [ __ ]
because you couldn't remember
chelsea handler's name after
all the [ __ ] i got about ming now when
but to be fair ming is more in our world
than our genre
i mean i shot hollywood babylon for a
long time
you should never forget chelsea handlers
right i should take my medicine well
done
um thank you for that vampire do you
have anything beyond a banff
man do you have anything beyond that did
you have any cool news i uh
i have some uh funny puns from simon
smith
in the chat uh earlier in the show when
you were talking about your
bird bingo uh simon said kevin your bird
bingo hosting was like
poultry in motion
i'm stealing that and i'm still what was
one you said mark um feather your nest
are so foul i'm going to use them so i
said to
simon that's hilarious and he said kev
isn't the only one with bird comedy
chops two can
play at that game
that's a good one i'm stealing that as
well uh
look martin k in europe says he said
it's past 2 a.m in europe going to sleep
now don't go to sleep martin k
this is this is not the point of the
show to go to sleep on
this is the q a portion of the show
that's why banff man is here that's why
i swung
in um this is the part of the show where
you
uh martin k are in charge man if you
uh martin k asked the question then
[ __ ]
we answer it man uh jc's just gotta pick
it
if you are one of the questioners martin
k so in any event
before one [ __ ] british viewer
we only have 12. i i hate to lose one of
them
listen martin if you go to sleep now
then freddie will get you
yeah really good stay awake martin tell
me that it worked martin k you better
you
write and tell me that you're still
awake martin okay
meantime yes i want to [ __ ] sleep
somebody wake martin k up for god's
sakes
and then you're putting petrol in my
lorry for the past
[ __ ] 15 hours and going to sleep
that's a pretty good accident right
there
meanwhile tt tells us best morning
show in australia is fat man beyond
because they're
they're just waking up over there so
this is somebody's monday morning show
today as we hear that you say in movies
and stuff like that
i i feel like we're leaving money on the
table by not going to australia and
getting a morning show
martin k is australian an austrian oh oh
i thought he was in he said europe and
in europe i thought he meant
you know i thought he meant england
he's in austria so you know that'd be
fair like come on he's like
i'm austrian [ __ ] you think i
want to stay up watch you answer
questions but you know what he proved
he's up
you got him mark k is listening he's
like oh you said my i don't know how to
do the austrian accent
i guess that would be arnold right ah
you used my name
speaking of hollywood babylon that was
useful because i didn't do arnold as
much as i did ralph
um all right banff man okay um
let's hear it uh this one is from larp
beard uh and i really like this one it's
uh
mark and kevin are army drivers hauling
a mysterious container out of area 51.
what are you hauling and how does it go
wrong
uh first off a little love to aj who
says hey
some love from kuwait it's 3am here
and i'm wide awake damn aj
rated milt rated mick rated mik mick
9 28 am in tokyo i don't know if he's
there or she's there but or if they're
just quoting times but you're just
looking at it
it's like you know what time it is in
newfoundland
nasty clam always good for a chuckle uh
said uh
10 27 on the east coast earlier
elsewhere
that's how time zones work that could be
said for a lot of things
all right so what am i hauling out of
area 51 yeah
that will eventually uh break out and do
massive damage
yeah and we've got a great big convoy um
it's it's going through the night we got
a great big convoy ain't she a beautiful
sight
come on and join our convoy ain't
nothing going to get on our way
we're going to roll this [ __ ] convoy
across the usa
convoy
[Laughter]
part of me is is wanting it to be like a
godzilla egg
because that could be cool and then it
goes wrong and you get a godzilla
and you know godzilla's tend to do a lot
of property damage
but then i kind of want to do like the
ark of the covenant like they finally if
i can pull it out of that warehouse and
decide to move
[Music]
that's my best john williams it's great
thank you
are you sure about this jewish ritual
yeah are you sure it's quite necessary
it's beautiful that guy
found out that it was [ __ ] quite
necessary you know as his face was
burning he was like i said we shouldn't
have done this you said it was a
transmitter
um what all right uh godzilla egg is
pretty hot
what am i gonna do and then i went ark
of the covenant ark of the covenant even
better
um all right what am i going for
oh ooh i'm going old school
but it's been a few years since they've
done it unless i'm wrong and i missed it
the blob ooh blobs nice
blobs a good concept could totally work
today i don't know why they're not
making blob movies left and right
where's the where's the [ __ ]
blumhouse blob movie like
huge like visual effects be so [ __ ]
easy
i like the the the 80s remake of it with
yeah
i love the 80s remake yeah like it is
incredibly impressive
when the black [ __ ] just like you lonnie
smith was in it
i loved that movie so much she came in
an audition on mall rats and mark
all i can say is i believe she hated the
script she was auditioning for
because like openly made fun of it
during her audition
i still remember this from 1995 because
i was like why would
one even come in like if you really
don't want the job and [ __ ]
but still i was like i love the blob man
and she didn't she was not impressed by
that either
but even though even after that and you
know encounter
i still love that blob movie i could
still watch that blob movie and i
watched it
within the last two years that holds up
man kevin dillon
mm-hmm i just remember the the the the
innovation that the blob also sort of
melted your bones and [ __ ] it was acidic
and so you got to see [ __ ] just
kind of disappear in the middle of it
it's like oh that's creepy
it was it was very very cool but yeah i
would pick the blob man [ __ ] blobs
out the truck and they're like no but
that was a cool premise
for to kick off army of the dead to be
like oh my god i got out
and this guy's going to that city and
that whole [ __ ] city
is wiped out now we're just walling that
city in and
maybe one day we'll do something and
then i thought it was dope that they
were like
you know we're gonna drop a bomb on you
know [ __ ] fourth of july weekend man
like
they turned it into an event and [ __ ]
felt real even though it was goofy you
know
zombie movie but it was like i bet you
that's what it'd be like if they had to
nuke one of our cities they'd be like
oh god yeah we're gonna put it on tv and
everybody's gonna watch it
huge rating yeah oh you know this will
be cool what if it's medusa
oh that's dope oh that is dope i like
that better because then you get a
little mythology going
on that surf and turf because you can
bring the crack in it
yes and then how do we kill the kraken
how do we get close enough to the kraken
how do you kill them all man you know
because with medusa
hey man make it pandora because that's a
box and opens and then
a bunch of [ __ ] nice
we got there netflix where's our money
yeah come on man
[ __ ] break some off for us forever
yeah city of the gods
[ __ ] that ask your kickstarter friends
yeah
i need 25 million dollars
somebody asked me in chapter like now
that mark's done this will you do this
with all your movies and i was like you
know
i've always stayed out of crowdsource
funding
because you know i i've
i'm not i'm not saying this about
anybody
previously who's used kickstarter to
finance a thing but
if you can walk into an executive's
office and pitch your movie
you know leave the kickstarter money to
folks like [ __ ] mark who are like
where else am i ever gonna have this
happen there's two schools of thought
some people like if a whale like you
comes to kickstarter it'll bring other
eyes but i feel like
if a whale like me first off i don't
appreciate being called whale but if a
whale like me did go to kickstarter
you're absorbing more than you're
bringing attention to other people and
stuff so i've always
stayed out of it for myself personally i
love the idea
like you know of kickstarter in fact
before
kickstarter or indiegogo existed we were
going to do a website called red state
green
to raise the money to make [ __ ] red
state and stuff
so i love indy uh you know financing i
love uh
not a group what is it called the
crowdsource financing i believe in it
but i feel like i've already made my
bones and i could
seriously walk into like a real money
place and and
have a 50 50 chance of walking out with
loot
as long as that still exists i have no
business
jumping into the small pond and soaking
up all the resources
for myself and again this is no judgment
about anybody who's ever
done that i don't want to see any
[ __ ] like smith don't like zach brab
i was very happy that
zach did it uh and stuff i just couldn't
ultimately do it for myself uh but i
i that's so going forward i i'm glad it
worked for mark but it still isn't
something that i would
choose to do i'd i'd rather self-finance
before i'd ask you for money because
i'm i know i'm gonna go to the audience
sooner or later for money
where i'm gonna be like yeah i need you
to give me your money when this [ __ ]
thing is done and it's in
the theaters or wherever the [ __ ] it is
and stuff so
that's that's the only reason it's not
like i don't believe in it
i do very much believe it and look at
what a dream come true story it's been
for my illustrious co-host here and
stuff um
i just think i'm you know i missed my
window
like i had my my window which was
somebody bought my [ __ ] movie put me
on the map put money behind my movie and
that's established me enough where i can
walk into a
studio and be like this is what i would
like to do rather than
taking what money could be potentially
used for projects like what mark's doing
away by swimming in those waters i
i've over explained it at this point and
hopefully insulted no one in the process
i mean i i felt very much the same way
going in because until i realized how
expensive this thing was going to be i
was like well i'll pay for it
like what are we looking at like i'll
cover this like i want to do it like
i'll pay for it
and i also went down the road of like
because i i am
similarly if i'm if i wanted to make a
tv show i could walk to the people who
make tv shows and say hey i'd like to
make a tv show
if this was a feature i simply could
have walked in and said hey i got this
idea for a movie
all right then then they will set up the
meetings and i'll walk and i'll pitch my
heart out
but there's no real audience there's no
market for a short
in that way and so nobody there nobody's
in the business of giving money for a
thing that can't make
money and so then it fell then let's
let's kickstart let's see how we do
let's roll these dice
and it came out what what an amazing
mechanism used
in such a wonderful way to such great
results
like it allowed your audience to give
you a [ __ ] pat on the back
and put money in your coffer so you can
go [ __ ] do the thing
it's spellbinding yeah um
so yes i would put medusa in the box
um because i think that'd be fun i like
it
greek me a world of greek mythology and
what that was real [ __ ] yeah it was all
real
yeah and there's minotaurs and [ __ ]
cyclopes
and but not in that [ __ ] you know
they've always been around and now
they're cops with will smith
away
something a little more i like yours
better it's just
nothing that's plausible but i like your
your approach
to material better yeah hello now i do
kind of want to see
the shitty version of just like minotaur
cop
who's like damn it will smith one more
time
i'm bouncing you out of here on your
horns um cassie banks
uh just uh put in the chat 88 dollars
away from 145
000 on kickstarter ladies and gentlemen
be a part of the splinter magic be a
splinter in splinter
go to kickstarter right now and help
mark out uh all right bam man come on
back
number two um question
my my choice for that what did you put
in the box
uh brassies and you make
yoga hosers too
i like the way you think why'd you wait
so long to come in on that one
you used your help i was struggling over
there going on the blob
you're right a little self-promotion
would have been the key bratzies for
those that don't [ __ ] know here's a
little
backstage history so um
there was there was no
yoga hosers movie like the one that
exists
now um
unless jc and i have a conversation
unless i actually
borrow or steal or take with his
permission
uh an idea from jc originally the girls
in yoga hosers were going to go
to um like a summer camp because my kid
was going to the summer camp program she
hated
and so i was just going to base it on
that and then jc
and andrew um both of whom are
responsible for our
weekly show when we're in the cantina um
told me that they're doing they were
thinking about doing or gonna do or
wrote a script
for a movie that like these
tell them what it was so it was uh
tonally
like um gremlins
meets goonies so um
it's it's four kids who
go into the woods in pacific palisades
one night and
uh there in real life there's actually
an old
nazi camp there that was around in the
early 1940s in pacific palisades
california
[ __ ] californians back in the day
were like well when the fuhrer comes to
america he's going to need a place to
stay and literally built
a [ __ ] nazi stronghold in the pacific
um so what in real life what happened is
um after pearl harbor the fbi came and
just
ransacked the place and then uh
hippies took it over in the 60s and
turned it into a commune and then it
burned down
in a fire but you can still hike down to
it so andrew and i
came up with this idea that there would
be a
hidden bunker underneath the wreckage
that these kids in 1985
discover the entry way to and unleash
uh hundreds of 12-inch tall
adolf hitler clones into the the hills
of california
and they have to spend the night killing
them
in all sorts of creative ways um
so that you know uh the nazis don't take
over the united states
uh on the fourth of july in 1985.
and i was like oh my god [ __ ] can i
have that
and so at first the yoga hosers
was
the girl's cbd the girls
um fighting
one-foot hitler clones um
that j muse was going to play jason muse
was going to play the
hitler clones all of them um
you know um evil dead
two three style mm-hmm where bruce
campbell was in multiple
little versions um called hitlands
like gremlins and that was like it for a
long time
and then like one day somebody was like
you know he was a real guy
and i was like i know and then we get to
kill him over and over and over again
in little miniature farm people stepping
on them and [ __ ] like that
and they're like yeah but like you know
like it's it's being mined for
children's comedy
and i was like perhaps we should rethink
this and so it became
bronzies instead because i was like i
said to
um bob kurtzman i was like hey man like
it can't just be [ __ ] little hitler
like it's got to be a thing
i was like so like you know he's from
germany what what
you know look what do you think of when
we think of german like i think of like
the black forest so maybe he's got skin
like a tree
bark or whatever and kurtzman was like
well i think of germany i think a
[ __ ]
sausage and i was like oh my god
so they became bratwurst and stuff but
it all begins
with jc talking about his miniature
hitler movie so if you were like what
yoga hosers what happened
if you're like when did you know your
career really started to go downhill
with that and i'd be like
my career started to go downhill long
before that madam
but if you're one of those yoga hosers
haters
see that guy
i've shielded them long enough send them
your enmity
but if you want to see my movie i did
have it budgeted
and uh similarly to marx it came in at
35 million dollars
so if everybody watching now donates
a hundred thousand dollars we can all
see that movie
the the thing is like mark you gotta
pick a number where people are like i
love you
because that's not asking me too much
like you know it was
it was a that was a sweet spot if you
all
if you all loved me 3 000 we could have
the teenage hitler hunter movie
there you go it's true this could still
happen
that's it man that's milton berle [ __ ]
like hey everybody
why don't you sneak into your parents
wallet
as uncle soupy was it to be sales
they call him uncle soupy or is he just
soupy's i think it's just soupy's house
but yeah
reach into your parents wallet take a
dollar then mail it to me here at the
soupy sales show in burbank california
the uh that reminds me of um
remember the episode of with gabo on the
simpsons
all those kids in springfield the rest
of these that was based on like an
incident where the channel was still
open yeah um
all right bam man okay
uh this is from my cat astrophy
um if you could cross over
any of the mtu motu characters
with any other ip what would you do
so you take one of the masters of the
eunuch universe characters and you put
them in
another ip um oh i
put skeletor into the star wars universe
for sure man
he [ __ ] you know he's he's about
power
technology and magic and that's like
darth vader country right there
so you know he's trying to escape hordak
and he winds up in the
star wars galaxy and teams up with vader
tries to take vader's spot so you get a
[ __ ] they fight
first they're going after you know
[ __ ] the good guys but then they wind
up fighting each other and [ __ ]
and then [ __ ] people are like let them
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
um but uh you know yeah i mean i guess
i mean look for our uh incarnation of
masters of the universe revelation
um it's very um it leans on
every you know [ __ ] franchise
that you love there's a lot of star wars
in it
and i'm talking about in our incarnation
there's a lot of star wars in it there's
a lot of lord of the rings in it
there's a lot of marvel movies in it you
know but it's
it's it's all the ingredients are
the chief elements of mattel characters
that you know and love and stuff
but the dna has baked into it a lot of
satisfying other
franchises that i've [ __ ] loved so
in my head i've crossed over with all of
them
because you know we cherry-picked um
feelings uh you know set pieces
arcs things like that um if you're gonna
do a thing do it right and there are
people who've been
telling stories like this better than me
for years and years going way back to my
childhood going back to the 70s
so we spared none of them in terms of
you know thank you thank you call them
homage
call it homage call theft but there's a
lot of
other great stuff at the root of of uh
our masters of the universe
revelation so i'm gonna go with star
wars and darth vader is the obvious
answer but
uh just know that if you had all those
action figures
for you know our version of master
universe you'd be able to play them
in almost any adventure
they're interchangeable um with many
different magical franchises superhero
franchises
a lot you know the the our motu our
version of
motu which the netflix internal
refers to as motur because motu is an
acronym for masters of the universe
they've just added the r for revelation
so they call me sir
um they um i forget what i was going to
say about that but
uh it was good it was tasty but then i
was like maybe i shouldn't
maybe i should be more circumspect um
yeah we'll just leave it at that but
i'll refer to him i'll button yours by
saying
how cool would it be to see your
skeletor
against mark hamill luke skywalker
it'd be like him fighting his own
you made my okay answer way better
because you get to then cross him over
that's true man so mark
is fighting mark a version of mark um
but not this mark what do you got mark
um
i am going to take cringer slash battle
cat
love him amazing character arc and motor
and put him in the lion king universe oh
who is he um i feel like he's you know a
cousin
from outside of town who comes to pride
rock he's like
why is this lion so green he's like
but then like [ __ ] goes down with hyenas
or scar and suddenly battle cat comes
out and it's like
oh damn and then all the other lady
lions are like
this weird green cat's got something
going on
and then mark won't be returning for
season two of motor
ladies and gentlemen yeah it's like you
do pitch the [ __ ]
like green lion sex on a podcast yes i
did
you did um that uh the cringer in our
show
is portrayed by the great steven root
and uh
he is nothing short of spell binding
it's so good funny as needed to be
heartfelt like you know
i'm i'm very happy with where cringer
goes in motor
yes makes me want to motorboat the show
it's we're just getting closer and
closer and i just have to be quiet
for a little longer and i'm finding it
harder to harder and harder
because there's so much love for it out
there man like people like i want this
and that was based on some pictures like
i keep obsessively watching the teaser
and i'm like wait until they they're
like they're going to absolutely [ __ ]
love it it's
yeah it's like it's like that thing when
you're on a road trip
and you're getting close to home but
you've also got to go to the bathroom
and so the closer you get to home the
more you've got to go to the bathroom
that's that's you and mo tour closer we
get to release
i'm ready to go to the bathroom all over
these people
that's that that's an r kelly i've ever
heard one take that back
uh oh mark b is checking in to give you
an update you're at a hundred and
seventy five thousand one hundred and
four
canadian on i was about to say like who
showed up and dropped 30 grand into the
till that's canadian my friend canadian
that's huge
huge figure you're canadian millionaire
it's a tv
though i believe um
all right bamf boy i think we've uh
man um my pick would be
to put trap jaw in real steel
or skeletor in pirates of the caribbean
because when he's when he goes out of
the moonlight
he you'd see his the way he looked
before
he was skeletor and then in the
moonlight he'd be skeletor
that's interesting and they had the last
bit but like
i thought those are good franchises to
put him into uh black belt jones i
thought
he poses motu as well uh black
belt jones in chat said man at arms and
gi joe
and if that isn't a perfect match i
don't i don't know that's not bad
um let me say this how about
uh we uh uh turned the
[ __ ] um can't goddamn it i smoked my
words away with cbd
um what if we did castle greyskull
inside uh
cantina hundreds
but definitely for part two hundred
percent yes
how cool oh that'd be dope man i'm into
that and that'll give people reason to
go if they've never been
to scum and villainy cantina and
hollywood on hollywood boulevard now's
your chance that things are opening up
out here in california ladies and
gentlemen june 15th
it's the wild wild west it's a
free-for-all they're going to let people
have sex in public
at that point of hollywood boulevard
right in the middle of ollywood
boulevard so
you'll be able to go into the cantina
and let me tell you something you've
been sitting around for a year
sitting on piles of money going like oh
i just want to spend it somewhere
where better than to go to the greatest
geek bar on the planet ladies and
gentlemen
um all right bam man people showed up
we've had we've had lines
out out the door every weekend people
are showing up
they missed us well don't brag now
you're making the rest of us with others
you feel bad we're not doing as well
this year
uh moviespopup.com and i'm going to be
in colorado in denver on wednesday for
the grand opening
cutting the ribbon and whatnot uh so if
you're interested in that sort of thing
and you're interested in uh having some
movies
in colorado moviespopup.com and we just
announced that we're going someplace
else what was it i guess that was it
is that right no no denver we just
announced
god damn it what denver no denver is
already on sale
am i crazy yeah because i'm going there
but we just what's the thing we just
announced
am i crazy there's another city let me
look at my twitter
where'd my phone go what the [ __ ] i'm
what's happening lost
and we're not even done with the show uh
hold on i gotta know this because it
really is bugging me is it milwaukee
that's it thank you it's milwaukee
my god that was gonna [ __ ] eat at my
soul we're coming to milwaukee ladies
and gentlemen milwaukee as you call it
milwaukee as we call it we announce
tomorrow i believe where it's going to
be
and what dates we're going to be there
so you can jump on the mailing list at
moviespopup.com
uh and that's also the same website you
go to if you want to
join us in denver at denver movies which
opens on wednesday which i will be there
to cut the ribbon at so if you've ever
wanted to take a picture with me wearing
this hat
oh you're about to have you
all right man last question uh this is
a little bit of a shift from the typical
but i thought
with mark's kickstarter is appropriate
uh ml
asked uh i was recently awarded an
awesome grant to make a short
any tips that kevin mark have for any
aspect of production
audience engagement or coping with
imposter syndrome
well first off imposter syndrome
no no no no no if you're about to shoot
your
first short you're no imposter um if
you're the type of person
that sits in a movie audience and
watches all the credits and you're not
there because you're hoping that [ __ ]
nick fury's gonna show up at the end
you're a filmmaker you just haven't made
a film yet
so ain't no such thing as imposter
syndrome my friend
especially if you're on the precipice of
making the [ __ ] thing
so don't worry about that and trust me
you won't the moment it kicks in the
moment you're there on set you're going
to be like
this is the right relationship this is
who i've wanted to be
my whole life as for the other questions
um you know pitfalls to look out for
just remember that uh this [ __ ] is fun
as [ __ ]
and you're breathing rarefied air as an
adult getting to make pretend like this
so you know ain't no reason to yell
ever ever uh raise your voice on a set
unless you're like look out the light is
about to fall on the [ __ ]
second lead or whatever the [ __ ] and in
which case i would just
scream ah or move or whatever [ __ ]
but ain't no reason to yell on a movie
set no reason to treat anybody
less than you everybody there on that
set doesn't matter if you got the top
job at the moment they're all there
making
making your story helping you tell your
story so
slobberingly grateful to these people
from top to bottom for lending
your their precious time to your art
which they don't know it's going to be
good or not they might not even be paid
they're just taking a leap of faith in a
lot of cases and stuff
so never take those people for granted
cast crew don't [ __ ] matter man
they're all
without these people this [ __ ] thing
lives inside you and eats away at you
like a cancer
these people are like doctors physicians
who are helping you
excise this creative cancer that's just
like i just i gotta get out it's gonna
they're gonna help you get them out so
make sure you always treat them well um
uh you know have an edit in your head
going in helps you to shoot it
sometimes you get on set and people you
know they always look to you how do you
want to shoot it what do you want to
shoot
you know even the dp is going to be like
well what do you need uh
some people are like we'll just shoot a
bunch of things and figure it out in the
edit
you can do that but that's costly you
want to save yourself some time and some
dimes
have a plan going in shoot the movie you
see
don't you know overshoot it don't
feel the need to get fancy and stuff
shoot the movie that you see in your
head and if that's limited and it's
storytelling
the dp can maybe help you expand it or
maybe it doesn't need expanding
but uh you know they're waiting for you
this is a job
if you're the director if i understand
it the question correctly
this is a job where you
are the only person who can communicate
the information
to the people you're working with they
they cannot see into your head you've
got the vision for the movie in your
head you could see it
nobody else can so they come up to you
and your job is to
answer their questions they're only
trying to help you get that movie out of
your head to the real world so be
prepared
as a director to answer a lot of
questions that is chiefly the [ __ ]
job
somebody comes up to you and says you
know uh
black or white you're like black
somebody's just like you know [ __ ]
jazz or disco you're like disco
somebody's like you know uh shag or thin
maybe like a shack like it's a series
of questions that you have to have an
answer for
at a moment's notice you know and if
you're like
i don't know let me think about shag and
get back to you like they'll smell blood
in the water and be like oh [ __ ]
you gotta be decisive and i don't mean
lie about it
i mean be decisive have an answer for
them give them an answer in that moment
you know if you can so because it's easy
you have the answers they're all locked
up in here and stuff
so they're not asking you complicated
budgetary questions they're asking you
how to build the world what the world
looks like inside your head
communicate with your crew and cast as
much as you can
don't hold up with the keys and you know
huddle up and whisper and [ __ ] and have
the information disseminated
i prefer to host the show like
host it like a like it's a [ __ ] show
and there's an audience and
i always have to tell everybody what's
going on i narry
as much as i direct so that everybody
understands what we're going for
share that information information is
power particularly on a movie set
so if the more you want to get what you
see in your head to come to life
the more information you got to share
with all those wonderful people
helping you make your dream come true my
two cents from a guy who's done it a
couple of times
uh i have never done it so i
will be in your in your same position um
i will say that as somebody who does not
have the experience of having been on a
set and being the person in charge
um and who knows he will be relying in
great
to a great degree on the people around
him to remember that you are the steward
of the story you want to tell
and you're the one who knows the most
about it than anybody else there
and so when all else fails lean back on
the fact that like you made this up
and every question that can be asked is
an answer you've already got
whether like kevin said you you have
thought about it deeply or not
it should be ringing true within your
head and so rely on the fact that yeah
you made this up
and so this is yours and when all else
fails protect the story
and make sure that the story is the
clearest thing coming forward
um i will say that i 100 believe
in imposter syndrome unlike because
i have i have felt it um i feel that
every time
i write a thing and give it to a person
um
even somebody that i that i like
somebody that i love it's the is this
the time they figured out that i'm a
fraud
i don't really believe that because i i
i know that there are certain things
that i'm good at
but there is always there's always that
bit of nervousness that bit of like you
know butterflies in your stomach
when somebody is going to read a thing
or see a thing for the first time
um it just takes some solace in the fact
that
lots of people feel this way and still
do the work
because it's just a thing it's another
hurdle that you just got to climb over
and the more you do it the lower the
hurdle becomes and you know
i i remember once interviewing damon
lindelof who said that every time he
writes something he feels that
he feels is this the time they figure
out that i've been i've been
running a long con on them the whole
time and if damon feels that way
then and still manages to do the work
then you can feel that way and still
mention your work as well
don't let it stop you in fact let it let
it
fuel the desire to make it great um
everything is is fuel for the engine um
if you know how to distill it right so
yeah
don't don't bang your head up against a
wall just uh embrace it
push forward and then and get it done it
is
you're getting people oh bathman is he
laser gentlemen he has some inside
i'll say i've done a few short films um
that were very very
like minuscule budgets um and a lot of
times
people aren't getting paid a lot of
times your friends are showing up
all that grant money goes on screen
you're probably going to be asking a lot
of favors
but those people are all there because
they believe in
what you're doing and and your ability
to get it done
so let that carry you
through your uncertainty because there
will be a team of people whether it's
three people or 10 people or 30 people
that are there because they believe in
you not because they're making uh robert
kirkman money
ooh robert kirkman money is what we all
aspire to ladies and gentlemen
indeed um
yeah kids don't fear impostor syndrome
you know like just understand that
anybody could do this [ __ ]
nobody nobody there's no i've been in
this business over a quarter of a
century there's no [ __ ] rules posted
on the wall that says
you got to be this scorsese good to ride
this ride
you know scorsese makes exquisite
[ __ ] movies don't mean that you can't
make
rudimentary [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying that's i've spent my
career making it that's what i'll
[ __ ] call my autobiography
rudimentary [ __ ]
the kevin smith story um you know don't
don't think that you got to be as good
as an nhl player to play some [ __ ]
hockey hockey's a fun game
grab a tennis ball [ __ ] hockey stick
go to a tennis court and [ __ ] and
have at it you know there's all
variations
on how to do it and there's bars of
excellence and whatnot
but just no such thing as an imposter
anybody can do this [ __ ] anybody
can make media doesn't mean you're going
to like it
doesn't mean it'll be any good to many
people but it's going to be good to the
person making it for sure
and i guarantee you based on experience
especially as the guy who made yoga
hosers
is good to somebody out there may not be
good to a whole bunch of people but
it finds its audience water finds its
level so
never feel like you're an imposter
everyone's at a [ __ ] imposter you
can't be an imposter
if there's no rules there's no standard
you know what i'm saying like
look at all the movies you love they run
the gamut some are brilliantly made and
some are [ __ ] goofy and simple if you
like my [ __ ]
if you're sitting here watching this
show you like goofy and standard movies
as much as you also like the
you know the really good stuff anybody
could play this game
don't feel like an imposter if you're
doing it if you're not doing it
that's you know you're a human being you
just got negative thoughts we all do
and [ __ ] but there's no such thing as an
imposter
if is the idea of an imposter syndrome
that you're not spielberg guess what
you're not nobody is just [ __ ]
spielberg
so is the idea that like i don't think i
should be doing something like this what
make and pretend
you were doing it when you were a kid
when you were a child did anybody ever
say like this [ __ ] kid
what an imposter no because make and
pretend is something anybody can do
so you know people get their [ __ ]
glasses fogged by the idea of like yeah
but there's money
and cameras and [ __ ] people and what
it's like anything else in life man
there is no such thing as an imposter
the moment you start doing it you're
doing it you're learning on the job as
you go experience certainly helps like
anything else but
don't you worry about it there ain't no
imposters out there even though
filmmaker you hate the [ __ ] most and
you may be staring at him right now
is not an imposter that filmmaker is
authentic because they've made a film
and guess what an audience somewhere
found it and enjoyed it maybe not
everybody but some did
ain't no imposters just bunch of people
trying it we're doing it
banff man
banff boy that took a where the [ __ ] did
you go you better be
off and got him saving a life you could
have drove a truck through that pause
what the [ __ ]
um i believe that's all of our questions
isn't it
that's all the questions for this week
there you go man it is uh that is a show
that's an entire show ladies and
gentlemen nothing but
show duck modoc is a show that you can
watch on hulu right now they're not a
sponsor but they sent us a bunch of free
crap
you know who is a sponsor and you gotta
go spend some money on the good folks
manscape did you like this show
did you have a good time or you're like
this show jumped the shark
so did that expression but are you
[ __ ] on the show do you want to
cancel it as the kids say uh
then just stop spending money at
manscaped
that'll go away but if you love us
ladies and gentlemen
if you like what we do here you support
us and lord knows you did mark this week
to a huge financial degree if you have
any money left over
go get some of that ball stuff going the
good fight batman 20.
yeah fat man 20's the code go to
manscaped.com
there's a fly fluent here it must be
summer must be coming mark
it must be or it's attracted by your
shorn balls that's true man he's like i
smell shorn balls blending strips ahead
i'm attracting them like flies literally
um
uh don't forget ladies and gentlemen the
scum and villainy cantina
is open right now so go to the website
and find out when you can go there and
[ __ ] imbibe
like a like we used to back in the day
amongst others i went to a restaurant
this week i went to uh
this is getting bougie but we had some
friends in from out of town austin's
parents so
uh we went to the ivy i hadn't been to
some time and ate at a restaurant that
was the first time i've done that
in over a year but you know it's like
you wear your mask everyone they
they make sure you got a [ __ ]
vaccination garden stuff
so but it was a great experience um
don't forget mark bernardin may have
reached lofty goals but hey man don't
mean you can't still donate
you can be a part of it carter you can
be a part of the man you want to be a
producer
side by side with kevin smith and
whatnot here's your opportunity man you
want to fund some art
made by the great mark barton here's
your opportunity to go to
kickstarter.com
and look for splinter what do you call
it splinter what splinter short
splinter short indeed um and you'll find
it and you can throw mark a little
financial love and stuff
yes i'm going to air kiss you from afar
if you want to throw
any financial love my way well there are
any number of ways to do that kids but
always just go to jayansylumbob.com
um that that's all the show we got for
you
for this sunday evening and that's like
three hours of [ __ ] show we didn't
even have a guest
unless mark is our guest that's a lot of
content ladies and gentlemen
hopefully you've enjoyed yourselves and
hopefully uh you've enjoyed
this time together i'm so glad we've had
this time together
cats that used to watch carol burnett
with your grandparents like i did
um right now mark before we get out of
here damien dusk
excellent [ __ ] name well played
damian dusk
says you're at 145 377 dollars
sweet fancy moses
banff and martin k has asked for
permission to go to sleep now
you know what martin k you've earned it
my austria my austrian friend
so in the words of your own people
go to bed
uh martin in the words of your fellow
countrymen
um uh
the best things in life are
to defeat your enemies see them driven
before you
know the lamentation of the women
rest well and dream of large women
martin k
if you can't be bothered to finish our
watching our show
then with you that's another
that's another conan reference kids
not that jason mama conan although that
wasn't bad at all but
i go classic conan
uh there it is kids uh come on back
next week we'll have some more [ __ ] for
you but for this week we're out of [ __ ]
we we gave you all yeah we really give a
[ __ ] and we gave it all to you
you took the [ __ ] your [ __ ] takers now
you go out and you enjoy the rest of
your
sunday don't forget if you're one of
them mayor of east town fans
it's about to start in about less than
an hour
yes i'll meet you with the wawa for some
water
that's good that's very that's
convincing you could be on that show
that's kate winslet good mark
get a little rolling rocks and some
yinglings congratulations uh once again
dude that's a huge
achievement and uh not just a testimony
to
uh you know the vision of a guy who's
like i'm going to direct before i'm 50
and stuff
but a testimony to the love they got
there they got for you out there
i know it i i have been profoundly moved
and touched
um by the events of the week so thank
you everybody for helping out
uh there it is kids look at that man we
[ __ ] had ourselves a show
uh last week we were together this week
we're back in our tiny boxes indeed
whether we're next to each other or
[ __ ] in video screens
or even on an nft crypto.jsonbob.com
um you will find me and mark together
doing this show there is no show
without mr mark bernard and give it up
for mr mark minor ladies thank you i i
look forward to the date and hopefully
that date is soon
uh at least judging by jc at least
mid-june
where we can be back together behind a
bar
um telling stories in front of people
and speaking of jc we all
uh say thank you banff man for rescuing
us from our boredom look at him swinging
in for his props
yes give me give me give me give me
kidney
uh thank you banff man for making this
all possible tell them where they
how they can pay you back uh just come
down and
get a drink at scum and villainy
oh and props to el toro 215 who created
the animated bam
graphic well done yes that was i thought
on twitter this week
thought it was adorable instantly texted
it to to uh banff man
and so we've had that the whole show
because
that very special fan who made that
little bamf animation
hey man we'll take more of that i mean
me and mark
we will take some intro bamfin or
something like that
oh yeah we just sit here he gets to come
in and out like a hero
mark's a star trek fan give him that
fazey [ __ ] you know
yeah i want to beam in yeah when he's
beaming into a place
me i you know i'm a stoner smoked me in
well that's kind of like the banff
so you know ooh remember that scene in
total recall where it's like
two weeks and the head comes apart
reverse of that
but i start like that and then i'm me
you know that thing not that
what a visionary he never [ __ ] did
anything he didn't see in some movie or
tv show of the muppets before
uh there it is kids thanks for hanging
out for fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i
am mark bernard
you better tune in next week ladies and
gentlemen same
fat time same fat channel uh
smodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith jeff's
a kiss ladies and gentlemen
you